Hello Freak bitches.
That's right.
We're back and this episode,
once again,
is brought to you by Squarespace. If you
have a company, if you have a business,
if you are a business,
say if you're an entertainer or maybe
an artist and you have something you'd
like to let the world know about it,
there is no better way to do it.
Then with your own website and for the
longest time that was a pain in the Dick.
You had to go find someone that you could
reliably count on to make you a nice
website and they they put didn't put
weird backdoors in it with a good sneak
Dick pics and all your photographs or
fuck with you and take too much time and
cost you too much money and
were were were, were, were.
When you rely on people, it's great when
it works out, it's awesome when you,
when you find someone like,
Oh,
I found this guy and he's great with
websites and he's my friend. Yay,
it's awesome.
It's fun,
but when it's a pain in the ass and
when it's not going well, you go, God,
I wish I could do this
myself. Well, yeah, it can.
Now today with Squarespace,
any moron like myself
could create a website,
a real professional looking website.
Brian is making a website
right now and he's,
he's done 30 of them, 40 of them. Why?
We've been doing Squarespace ads
every week while we do commercial.
Brian puts together a website.
It's that fucking easy. Hey,
just made a t shirt for Tony.
You didn't even have a tee shirt
builder where you can sit in there.
They have a logo builder, you could
design your own custom logos very easily.
All this is drag and drop type interface,
so it's all like,
same thing you would do if you were
you like if you can add pictures to an
email,
you can figure out how to do this.
It's not hard to do and you can make an
outstanding professional website with 24
seven support. If you fucking
your middle and my website suck,
like you figure this out,
you can get ahold of Squarespace and
they'll hook you up. Squarespace.
Simple and easy design.
They have platforms at work or it
works rather on every platform.
It'll work on iPad to work on
android and a work on windows.
It'll work on Unix.
Squarespace can help you design your
own website where you can like have an
immediate professional
website with a store.
Easy to put together an online store,
easy to sell digital downloads.
Say if the Golden Pony, Tony
Hinchcliffe decides to start pop music.
And I think you could, I think it could
be one of those Dj's like at a rave,
like pumping your fist dead mouse style.
That could be you in another life.
Anyway,
squarespace.com and use the code word Joe,
go to squarespace.com
use the code word Joe.
Get a free trial and 10%
off your first purchase.
So go to squarespace.com and
enter in the code Joe Squarespace.
A better web starts with your
website. That's Hilarious, isn't it?
A better web starts.
How about saying nothing?
And it's better than a better web starts
with your own website because you can't
do that. This is the Internet,
right? This is in fucking Nabisco.
A better web starts with your website.
That's amazing because that's already
better than my actual website and I just
watched you make it intense seconds
and it's better than my tee shirt.
That's incredible. The ones that we
judged, we had a Squarespace condos.
It's like end of the year contest.
They develop some killer fucking website.
I still visit that. Uh, there's
a storm website that uh,
I don't remember the URL,
but the sky like took all these crazy
photographs of nutty cloud formations and
storms coming. Oh, it's awesome.
And it looks like he paid
a fucking fortune to make
this website and did it all
himself or herself. I don't know
if it's a guy or Gal. Uh, anyway,
go to squarespace.com and use the code
word Joe for a free trial and 10% off
your first purchase.
Squarespace.
It's also lets you try it out before you
enter in your credit card information.
You can sign up, start building your
own website and go, you know what,
this shit is dope,
this shit is fly.
And then you can enter your
credit card and when you do that,
use a codeword Joe and
save 10% off dead to,
we're also brought to you by ting.
Ting is a cell phone company that does
things in a way that I think is the
future tings. A website where
you can go there. First of all,
if you, if you look at like the,
the big cell phone providers,
whether it's a sprint or whether
it's a Verizon or at, and, t,
one of the things that bothers people
is early termination fees like can get
getting hooked into a contract.
The reason why you do that and uh,
it's very convenient for,
you know,
for most of us because what they're doing
is instead of paying the full amount
for a cell phone,
usually like it says it's two 99 but
60 99 if you want to buy it on its own.
Yeah, that's, that's the
different thing that to 99,
when you buy it with like a two year
contract, if you break that contract,
you have to pay that money.
What you're doing sort of deferring that
money over a long period of time and if
you want to get out, he can't
get out. You're like, Shit. Um,
ting has it so you can get out of
anytime you want. You buy the phone,
you own the phone, they sell the
best android phones you can buy,
including the Samsung Galaxy note
three, which I have. It's awesome phone.
So the really cool, you can write on
it. It's got a little stylus and shit.
The images are gigantic for going on
the web. It's fucking unparalleled.
There's nothing like it.
Like an iPhone is great for usability
and you can bring your iPhones also,
um, from sprint and they can pour them to
tank and then they sell the iPhone five
for 260 bucks. You can actually buy
it for 260 bucks and then it's yours.
You own that shit son. No contract. Yeah.
And the way 10 uses it to 98% of
people would save money using tank.
That's their claim, not mine. Cause I'm
no statistic Titian it's, it's at us.
Titian it's my note three is about
one eighth of my cell phone price for
my iPhone. Yeah, it's pretty cheap.
I think I pay on average
about 20 bucks a month.
It's a $21 a month is the average month
monthly bill. So you have an average bill
below average like northern walls.
bucks is the average annual savings
per device for a business with 11 to 20
employees. It's pretty sweet.
Um, and I said, like I said,
all of the best android cell phones,
no termination fees.
Go to Rogan dot [inaudible] dot com and
you can save 25 bucks off your first
device.
10 uses the sprint backlog backbone.
So it's not like it's some
wonky ass cell phone network.
They use one of the best cell
phone networks in the world.
And the sprint backbone is you give the
exact same sub service and coverage that
you would if you had sprint,
but you're using a ting device and you
can quit any time you want and it's all
set up on their terms.
An ethical company providing you with an
awesome service and everyone that I've
talked to about it, they've all loved
it. Chris Ryan uses it. Brian uses it.
It's a sweet,
easy way to save money.
Nowadays you're always on a wifi network
because you're usually always at home
or you're always at work
and stuff like that.
So a lot of people are on these plans
now that don't make any sense because no
one's really making phone calls anymore.
You remember when it minutes
were a big thing. No one's,
everyone's texting now and you're,
if you're texting and you're
connected to your Wifi,
a lot of these phones will
just like, Oh, you're,
you're just using this wifi network.
You're not even using tings network. So
I think it's important to still talk
to people on the phone. I really do.
I think we're getting a little weird, a
little weird. We go days in and you know,
it talks to us like, look, you
only just text all your friends.
I mean maybe there's some benefit to that
sometimes when you want to decompress,
but I think for the most part we should
probably talk to each other every now
and again. It is interesting.
It's like we're going backwards.
I'm one of the to stuff it and just go
carrier pigeon or raising like in game of
Thrones, that's going to be the mode
that's going to be the coolest guy in the
neighborhood.
The guy that gets it has the first
raven that's trained to drop stuff off
somewhere. It's going to be, how
hard is it to train up fucking raven.
Didn't want to listen to what, all
right. I think could go anywhere.
They can do anything fly and the
fucking smart and it's not, I'm like,
there's no food. Right. You
know, they can find food.
They don't need to listen to
your bullshit or an animal.
So smart to travel long distances.
You think they'd be smart enough to
realize they don't have to take that shit.
You know, they could just go do
whatever they want. You know,
it's a really fucked up
feeling or a thought rather.
What if that's how Raven's
involved evolved their
intelligence cause ravens are
so smart,
they do all these multistep process tests
where raven has to get a stick and use
the stick to get a bigger stick and use
that bigger stick to get an even larger
stick cause they're all
down these long tubes.
So the Raven keeps figuring out
that as it gets longer sticks,
he can reach and scoop the law,
the stick that's longer than that and
pull it out and then drop it and then use
that one to get a piece of meat.
And they do it Loos like seven or
eight steps and you watch it and ego.
That is freaking me the fuck out.
That thing is smart at Shit. Yeah.
They're probably so smart
that they figured out how to not
have to be the male Guy Anymore
or Ravens and crows the same. Um,
I, that's a very good question.
I think not. Yeah. But it
seems like it should be right.
Or Ravens and crows as shame. I think
they're both blackbirds but, uh,
that's just the word just being racist.
Racist. No, it's a good question.
I'll read from what parts are all
this year or Ravens and crows.
The Samsung Different since
treating crows and ravens.
There was a crow fight my backyard a
couple of weeks ago and I had crow was
injured in Atlanta in my backyard and I
couldn't get out, kind of fly anymore,
so I just wanted to go out, you know,
take my dog out to go to the bathroom.
And the second I would come out,
all the crows and neighborhood
would just start going crazy.
Like swooping down,
like trying to protect the injured one.
Their smartest shit. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. It's weird.
Like we think of him as just birds,
but they're like a little gang.
They're a gang of little flying
monkeys. Um, this is the, the,
the explanation.
A raven is a bigger version of a crow,
although they are the same species.
A Raven has common name given to the
largest species of birds in the genus.
Core of us.
Corvids are commonly referred to as
Chros and other species in the same genus
you see, Janice or Jenice
gives you say Janice. Right?
That's why I only read though. I never say
like Gina's, it doesn't really come up.
If you use genus, had a conversation,
you're a Douche. She totally,
unless you're a biologist
and he's a genius and you're
like, what are you doing?
You stop it. You just stop. Cut Your
fucking fanciness. Little there for him.
The genius. Um, corvids. Okay,
so that's what it is. And uh,
they're the same, uh, Jean
needs as Jack Dawes and rooks.
I don't know what any of those birds
are. There you go. So now you know,
go to wikipedia.org and look
up ravens and that's it.
Ting rogan.tank.com.
Awesome cell phone company.
I love that.
25 bucks. Boom. Schelok lock. Boom. Oh,
I'm Ian Edwards has a new CD that's
out right now and it's on the team.
Coco label team coco meaning of course
the great Conan O'brien has his own
record label, I guess. And he's, I'm
putting out, this is the first one. Yeah.
And Ian Edwards, our friend,
fucking a hundred percent
awesome. He calls, uh, his,
his CD's called 100% halfassed and it's
Ian sitting on the edge of his bed.
Two would stand up cause that's where
he'd like to be able to do his dad though.
He's just a super funny dude and one of
the nicest guys I know and I've known
Ian Forever and he's just cool as
shit. So a support support. Um,
and he's really funny man. Really Fun. I
guarantee you enjoy the shit out of it.
So go to records.team coco.com and you
could see a Ian Edwards a hundred percent
halfassed this weekend. I will be with
the Great Tony Hinchcliffe and uh,
the Great Brian Cowen
we're going to be in. Um,
we were in Lloydminster on Thursday
and then we are in Vancouver on Friday.
Vancouver is the Orpheum theater.
I'm not sure what's,
I think one of them sold out.
I think it's the Lloydminster
one or really close.
So if you want to get you free, come
with us. Jump on it, bitches. All right,
that's it. Boom. Shall lock lock bone.
We don't need any other fucking
goddamn advertisements. Cue The music.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
brain with Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast my night.
Good
googly Mooglie,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
googly mooglie fresh back from Indiana,
letting those middle America
people know what the fuck is up.
Middle America is a lot like middle
earth in some ways. You know, you know,
middle earth like where the hobbits lived,
the good folk wasn't middle earth like
the cool people. That's where the uh,
the hobbits where I don't know about that,
but I do know that Indianapolis,
I learned something this weekend about
Indianapolis and that's that it's like
the south of the Midwest.
Southern a lot of ways. Yeah.
It's amazing though because
it's pretty much straight uh,
west of Columbus.
But they're like,
and they were laughing about
it so I'm not insulting them,
but there are a lot more like a hook,
a hook. Then the city is around them.
Like you just go a few miles down the
road and all of a sudden it's all about
racing and it's all about guns and a
lot of Camo shorts I saw cause it's
starting to be summer there.
So
yeah, there are, there's a lot of
country music lovers there, Kentucky.
Like you'd never think that Kentucky's
right next to Cincinnati. Yeah. You know,
like you think of Cincinnati,
Cincinnati, wk Rp.
Remember that show with Loni Anderson.
You think of Cincinnati is like a city.
You think of Kentucky as, Oh
man. What's going on down there?
A lot of Banjo picking and
moonshine making barbecue and
woo.
You don't think it's right,
right next to Cincinnati and Cincinnati
airports in Kentucky. Oh it is? Yeah.
And you land in Kentucky.
They call it the Cincinnati
airport because they're
ashamed they're in Kentucky.
That's so sad. And I'm like, you know
Kentucky people. Kentucky's awesome.
Louisville is awesome. You Know
Kentucky Fried Chicken. All right.
You guys are known for Bourbon.
Like you guys make some great shit.
Kentucky's were Corvettes are made the,
they make all their Corvettes
and Kentucky, Jeremy Clarkson,
the guy from top gear who's
driving this corvette and uh, he,
he likes yelled out like
while I was driving it,
well done fad man from Kentucky,
you have created a masterpiece
that you're going to,
if he's going to yell out the n word or,
so he did that later.
He did that though. That poor
bastard. People have hubris man.
They think they can say things like that.
I read something cool about Kentucky
Fried Chicken since you brought it up.
I'm going to say it,
it's a the kernel like whoever the actual
KFC guy was his protege or like the
person who he trained underneath him.
Favorite guy coming up the ranks of like
fast food, uh, helped him out a lot.
Like chain made some major decisions was
the guy that told him put the chicken
in a bucket instead of a box.
This guy was Dave Thomas who then
went on to make all the Wendy's
Whoa, powerful, fast food
conspiracy theory. But
it's a fact like some shit that your
friends told you when you were in high
school. It turned out to be totally
false, but you repeated forever.
Nabisco is owned by the same
people who make missiles.
They're trying to kill you
one way or another, bro.
It's either with cupcakes
or with missiles.
Well, it is the same company
that makes cigarettes.
Nabisco is RJ Reynolds and Rjr Nabisco.
Rj R is RJ rental.
Impossible. The people feeding you
Twinkies would not hate what you did.
Is that Nabisco where they Twinkies
and the Bisco have Twinkies? No.
Who had Twinkies and hostess.
Hostess. It's not the same,
but it could be under the same
painful,
but Nabisco is, I'm known
as being like, you know,
if you think of like snacks,
right?
You think of like something that's
Yummy but not necessarily good for you.
I picture the Nilla wafers.
I remember those. Yeah.
What did they have that's like
real bullshit. No. Pisco Pisco.
They have some good chocolate
chip cookies. Yeah, right? Yeah.
The Bisco some good God, they got
the chip Keebler elves on their side.
I do believe, check this out. Dave
Thomas and Colonel Sanders. Uh, both guy,
uh, they both won first place
and they tied a for who split?
Who could best fried chicken. Wow. Dave
Thomas' chicken. Why doesn't Dave Thomas,
just so, I mean he's dead
now, but when he was alive,
why didn't you sell chicken at one day?
He did. There was a test market. Uh,
what they do. So checking in when he's,
but there was a Tuscan sandwiches.
They don't yet,
you can't get it like a bucket of chicken.
There was a test market
company that Wendy's started
that I only think stayed in
Columbus or at least Ohio called sister's
chicken. I don't know if you think it,
it sounds, I remember that. And they,
they actually were way better
than Kentucky Fried Chicken.
They had these little chicken littles and,
Oh man, it was a chicken littles like,
uh, like uh, you know, get, it was, it was
like white castles, but with chicken. Oh,
this is like the Steve jobs of fast.
He figured out a lot of shit with
Wendy's. Yeah. Like you really did.
Like one of the things was that the
food is never frozen. Like if you,
if you get a steak or a
hamburger patty steak,
if you got a hamburger patty from
any other place, it's usually frozen.
And they just sorta like,
if you look at some of them,
they didn't even look like
meat, like white castle. It
doesn't even look like me.
Right. So confusing you looking at what
a white castle burger is. It's delicious.
But you're like,
what the fuck am I eating?
But if you look at Wendy's like they
can, they get their patties, they're big,
thick patties and they get
them and they just, they don't,
they don't ever freeze them.
They just throw them right onto the grill,
which has gotta be better. Right? Yeah.
The less you can free shit you got.
Think like when you're eating things,
you're kind of taking in like live
cultures. Like if you eat yogurt,
you taken live bacteria,
you know,
and when you eat like anything,
whether it's um, whether it's, um,
the, any kinds of foods sort of have
like some sort of bacteria fungus on it,
just a slight amount.
And so when you're taking them in,
you're taking in like living things
whenever you just totally freezing
fuck out of living things ever good.
I just can't be good.
There's something, something's got
to be missing there. I don't, I mean,
I'm no scientist,
but I think when you freeze it till
it's like literally it doesn't rot.
Like just, it's not supposed to happen.
That's supposed to be fucked. Yeah.
You know, like if you have
crops and your crops freeze,
you're supposed to be fucked. You
know? That's what it's supposed to be.
It's not supposed to be free shit.
And you're eating like frozen peas.
Like what does,
what does even in those things,
that shit ain't a regular p that's
got to cut something. Right.
And that stuff gets frozen on the surface
of a thing. I would like to see a sign
ticket analysis,
maybe I'm totally wrong,
but I would from my Wu wolf bro Woo
factor, how I would describe it,
uh, I would say you're losing the
essence of the life form of plant.
Once you freeze it and kill it,
everything's dead.
Like that's the reason why it's not
rotting is all that bacteria that would
normally break down anything that
you leave out and it starts to decay.
That's all on the surface of that anyway.
Right? I mean, it just takes time to rot.
That's what it is.
Thoughts that you have some dead
bacteria instead of live bacteria on the
surface of your thing.
Yeah, that's gotta be part
of it. I mean, isn't that,
that is what like taking live cultures,
it was all about like everybody wants
to eat probiotic stuff like probiotic.
I have some probiotic Sauerkraut, man,
it was amazing. What does probiotic mean?
It means it's rotting like
probiotic. Sauerkraut is, it's like,
it's almost like carbonated. You ever
have that stuff? It's like fermented. Oh,
I've had it. Yeah. It's
really good. I love it.
It's delicious and super good for you.
It's like a lot of people don't know like
raw sauerkraut is fucking really good
for you. Oh yeah. It's a,
it's got a live thing you're taking into
your body and that live cultures very
good for fighting off diseases and
for balancing your stomach and for,
there's a lot of people that they're
connecting him with autism and a lot of
ways because a lot of people with autism
also have a bowel issues and gut issues
and they think that uh,
it could possibly be connected to like a
wrong balance of bacteria in your body.
Right.
Which is fascinating man.
Yeah.
Sauerkrauts one of the few things that
is good for you and completely delicious
at the same crazy is that like
it makes a hot dog 50% better,
easily sausage.
He could put it.
Any is Tony Making Sauerkraut?
It's one of those foods where you could
like smell it and picture it right in
front of you. The good like
Brown, seedy mustard. Oh.
Or figure that out. Like all the other
vegetables must to be so jealous.
They don't get to be on the hot dogs.
You get like pickles and you know,
it's like cucumbers and Sauerkraut.
Those are the happy ones.
Every once in tomatoes kind of bullshit
on my cheeseburger. Totally. The
fuck is that. All those cool vegetables
hate on the lettuce and tomatoes.
Why should let us into men will be
allowed to be on a cheeseburger like, Ooh,
it's per tune. This is healthy.
Let us is less than nothing.
What's the difference between
our bratwurst and a sausage?
That's a good question. Maybe it's a
niche. It must be the preparation right?
In Ohio.
Bratwurst were everywhere.
Like there was restaurants that
specialize in brought where's here?
I'm always looking for a broad words. Now
you can only find sausages or hot dogs.
There's gotta be a place.
I know you can get them at the store.
I think bratwurst might be a
little bit of a smokey or flavor.
That's my guests going into it. I
have no idea. That's talk sausage,
Ravens and sausages.
Okay. The same difference
is this between a square and a rectangle.
What?
You've just broken a bratwurst. Okay.
This is the weirdest. Again, whatever
the guys had. A square is a rectangle,
but a rectangle is not
a square. Oh, I see. Um,
so is a bratwurst a sausage.
But any sauce where is not
a bratwurst brought worst.
Our pork sausage with a medium grind
spiced mainly with pepper sausage is any
ground meat in casing. Hmm. So
it seems like it's a sausage.
It's just a different type of sausage
that's saw. It is, I mean it's,
it's a pork sausage.
You can call it a bratwurst all you want.
That's a creepy word to WHO's,
what is that? Yeah, German tours.
What do you think caused certain parts
of the world to develop that sound like
that?
Like when you get like weird sounds
brothel or weird fucking language sounds,
those sounds that people in
that region made like what kind,
what got them to do that?
It's crazy. It's like they think the
opposite of us. Like, Oh, I'm in American,
I annunciate my,
you know what I mean?
Like that's what's crazy is we look at
them like they're weird and they look,
imagine how weird we sound.
Like,
if you think of what they sound
like and what we sound like,
their perspective must be like,
I must sound like where like
singing things because it's so pure.
Well,
we're a fascinating example for the rest
of the world because if you look at all
the other English languages in the world,
they all are pretty similar.
Australian and New Zealand. I mean,
I've got a good day. You know,
they got a little bit of a difference,
but it still sounds like an
English accent. It's like
an altered English accent.
Whereas we got over here and went,
Nah, not so much. No, we're going
to say it our way. Fuck base,
and we're going to make more bombs and
we're gonna make it tell everybody talks
your waist weird.
Now you're going to have to learn our way.
The English language is
quite weird because you're
somewhere and you're talking
to a man.
He's still talking about this.
So I'm having a hard time understanding
you right now. That's not English.
This is English fucker here.
That nice and clean.
No fucking words slurring into
the next word like word soup.
You're going to Goddamn word, food,
train, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
We're perfect over here in America.
You know how to rocket.
We fucking got took your language
and linseed it. We made it better.
See your language bitch. Who's our shooter
of the day? I haven't heard yet today.
I hope they catch him. Flocker, man,
it's got an ugly dude that north
Hollywood shit was crazy. That dude,
the North Hollywood thing
for folks who don't know,
there was a man on a roof and I thought
I saw it from Eliza slushing jurors.
Twitter.
Eliza slessinger was
torturing her ex boyfriend,
uh, on a, on Twitter.
She dated a guy slessinger that
made up a complete total history.
He said his mom was dying. His mom was
fine. There's nothing wrong with mom.
Said he went to the Yale.
He never went to Yale.
He said he was starting
up all these businesses.
The guy was like $100,000 in debt. Like
he, he was like living with roommates.
Like he was just,
he totally fabricated as super successful.
Eliza Schlesinger got Sarah Tiana,
she got Sarah. Tiana said, Whoa,
she got Sarah Tiana and hardcore,
but she was going off on our Twitter
and then I saw something about,
shoot the guy on the roof. And I'm like,
what kind? The roof? Like, you know,
she was saying, kill that
fucking guy. She's so crazy.
And then I went and then I started
looking, uh, looking up stories.
What exactly is the,
the full cool?
Well,
what pretty much happened is it started
off as a police chase and then it went
on. Like it was one of those ones that
just went on every single highway.
And the guy finally got out out in north
Hollywood and he just got out of his
car. And when he, he was driving,
he was holding out a big, uh, rifle.
Hey automated rifle, just like
hanging out the window. And so, uh,
he pulls his car over in north Hollywood
and he gets out of his car and he pulls
out this huge gun and he just starts
walking down North Hollywood with his gun.
And then he gets on top of a roof
of a house. And then at that time,
that's when I tuned in because
I saw Eliza tweet also,
and then I thought he was just
going to shoot himself, but he just,
for about 20 minutes,
he was on top of a roof with a gun and
then he comes down off the roof and he
breaks into this house.
Luckily there was nobody home and he just
sat in the house for about four hours.
That's when it like the movie,
I mean the,
the real life just completely
became boring. Like there's,
so the news for like three
hours or however long it
was just repeating the same
thing over and over for three hours.
Finally they got the Swat team all around
the house and they shot in a bunch of
containers, uh, of smoke
or whatever, pure gas.
And the guy just walks out.
But what was the coolest thing is that
the two police dogs just came running up
to him, sniffed his leg, and then sat down
right next to him. Like just like, hey,
we're waiting for a whistle before we
just chew your Dick Apart, you know?
And the guy just like,
you know, surrendered.
So it was a really crazy beginning part
of the movie or thing and then it just
sucked at the end. Well it seems like
more hours, you know, problem where we
have a short attention span,
we want all live,
all these live altercations to go down
as if they're a 90 minute movie that we
can pay attention to.
Yeah. But I mean just yesterday
there was somebody in Vegas, the,
I don't know if you saw
the Walmart incident that
happened in or the day before
and do you think this is copycat shit,
I, I think something's going on man.
Cause this,
I was talking about it four days ago.
Like how we'd been having
a shooter every day.
There was that guy in Canada that I
don't even know if they ever caught in
Canada. The guy that was just had like
three guns and he was going through
neighborhoods,
shooting cops and stuff.
Yeah. He was shooting those guys who
look like Bullwinkle's buddy. Yeah.
They dress like bowling legals pal.
Canadian royal mounties. Yeah they,
it's a horrible story.
You shot like three of them up there and
someone I met someone who knew that guy,
I can't remember the exact thing,
but they, they uh, weren't surprised.
It seems like it is kind of like a weird
copycat thing now because I mean we'd
been having it ever since
the Santa Barbara Douchebag.
Well, there's a lot of people out there
that are probably on the edge and it just
takes one thing like that to push them.
Yeah. The, the, the, the school
things with these that, you know,
like I saw a part of that
kid's video where he's like,
I'm going to keep them all.
And it's like terrifying.
He was talking like he was doing
something much bigger than shooting a few
people. He was saying things like,
oh, you're all going to, you know,
I'm going to show America or the world,
like he's talking on such a grand scale.
And uh,
I think that they really think that it's
even bigger than it is and that they're
like a hero or something. Like they're
going to be remembered for that.
Well, they know that that's the
thing that people are most afraid of.
So you can cause that thing to happen.
You become famous.
I mean it's that simple and they equate
in their head being famous in that way
is having an impact.
And you know,
obviously the guy had a huge impact
with all the people's families that he
killed. That guy just drove around
and killed his three roommates.
What was fascinating,
it was that that became this like
a woman's rights sort of a Hashtag.
Yes. All women, you know, or uh, I
wouldn't say, I wouldn't say woman rights,
like awareness,
awareness of a violence that women face.
And I got admitted. It makes you think
about it in a different way that the,
that hashtags a great
hashtag. Yes. All women.
Because not all men have to worry about
the things that women have to worry
about. Like you don't have to
worry about being raped by checks.
You don't have to worry about,
you know,
like women beating you up
or women's stealing things
from you or women trying to
rape you.
You don't have to worry about it.
But women have to worry about it from men.
Like it's a whole different world
they live in. You know, it's,
it's hard to think about when
you're live in your world, you know,
your world's pretty easy.
You're super between,
right. Well yeah, I was
going to on about 130 pounds,
so I'm pretty sure I can be
raped in any given point.
I know a little hashtags should
be yes. All women. Antonia hint,
I know what it's like to be a
woman. Or do you when uh, someone
said that from the WHO?
Pete Townsend said that,
so he knows what it's like to be a
woman. Oh, what is a woman? Really? Yeah.
It was some crazy claim or some crazy,
a statement about, uh, you know,
haven't had bisexual experience.
The towns, it's one of those guys,
like if you do a little research,
he has some crazy stuff about him,
but he can get away with anything because
he's the lead guitarist from the hill
and he does that windmill
thing and you know,
when you're that cool you could be crazy.
But he has like some crazy history.
He got investigated for child
pornography. Yeah. And uh,
he said that he was doing it for some
sort of a research project or something
like that.
It was researching child pornography.
So in doing so he's searching for it.
Yeah. I don't remember what the project
was that he was involved with that he was
saying he was involved with,
but that's kind of fucked.
There's one woman that could beat up.
You were talking about there's no,
that guys can get raped by
women and stuff like that.
Did you see that woman that beat up that
little 17 year old kid and he filmed
the whole thing on the Connecticut beach.
There's chicks like that out there
while she was beating him up. Yeah.
There's this woman in Connecticut.
He was flying when those little
toy drones on the beach and uh,
it has little cameras in it and she
thought she crazy woman like, oh,
he's recording us like it's
illegal or something to do that.
And she started like calling the police
and he started filming it on his iPhone,
what she was doing. And right when
she got off the phone with the police,
like she's like,
you better get here.
I got him right now because I felt and
just starts beating this kid up and he's
filming the whole thing like that.
After I saw this video,
I actually had to go in the other
room and just sit down cause I was,
my heart was racing so hard. I just want
you to kill somebody after watching.
You should w would you like to look at it?
Really you? You're fucking this woman.
I want to find this woman.
This is going to drive you crazy. Okay.
Let's see here. Okay, check it. Love this.
Yes.
Make me mad.
You had to go sit in another room because
your heart was beating him. Okay, buddy.
Brilliant.
Okay.
Andrew Mirrors 23 did not appreciate
this man flying his drone on the beach.
She was under the impression she had
an air pack perception of privacy on a
public page,
pictures and try and upload
them from a or from a para.
Can you guys get here at Hammonasset at
now realizing this video recording her.
He's taking pictures of people on the
beach with like with a helicopter plane.
Wow.
Can you guys
video kept him from getting arrested
cause she said that he had assaulted her
dude. They released him after they
showed the video from the iPhone.
Stop. Stop, stop, stop.
I know it gets so fucked up.
Well right now all you're seen is this
kid holding onto his equipment and the
woman is a confronting him.
He's trying to put his equipment away.
You're a thought layman.
You asked why?
Oh whoa.
She's like really hard to
see what's happening here.
Yeah, I think this is fake. No,
it's not. The woman was arrested.
Is this on the news and
what is this guy doing?
That's a weird half guard looking at her
hands are ripping it there. His mouth.
Yeah. She's putting her hands in his
mouth and he's filming it the entire time.
Like as a selfie. Smart.
It's hilarious actually.
Oh my God, this girl's crazy.
She got terrible half guard.
If you weren't assaulting me,
I wouldn't be touching. You
want to stop assaulting me?
Get off of me.
Call the cops. I me. It's not bad.
Wow.
He's just totally playing. All
right. He's not really scared.
She just happy that he's filming all this.
Please get off of me.
Wow.
That make video. It makes me crazy.
This is photography's not a crime.
It's amazing that he got that.
Why does that make you so mad to me?
It's funny because I've been in
situations psych. Hi. Yeah. I mean,
it's funny is he wasn't in danger.
He was doing this the whole time.
He wasn't like,
he was like making sure he filmed this
girl beating the shit out of him. Right.
Like you didn't even like stop or
defend himself. He wasn't scared.
I had been in domestic violence
plate things before though and Shit.
That shit where she could have just said,
yeah,
he attacked me and stuff like that shit.
Now he did say that like,
that's why I know that your
situation drives me nuts.
That's back where it makes me want to
have a Gopro on the recording all day.
Yeah,
no. Yeah, the salted
by chicks all day long.
Brian's upload and all day it'd
be like chicks punching up,
holding him down in the parking lot
and kicking the ball and he just wasn't
telling us about these get over me.
He was just keeping all
these from us cause he was
talking about it on this show.
It's like, you know, every day
another one I'm going to bring it up.
No fuck are they going to
make fun of me all day? Just
chics beating his ass.
Yeah. I don't know man.
I mean she's obviously an asshole,
but he was like letting her get away
with it on purpose. It is amazing.
It is amazing. Five, 10 years
ago that same thing happens.
That's 17 year old who was just
flying his plane on a beach,
ends up going to jail because if a woman
does say this guy assaulted me and the
cops come there and they see his shirt
half ripped as if she was in a defensive
position. You know what I
mean? Absolutely. It's amazing.
There's no doubt. There's no
doubt. Well she said that she,
that he was assaulted or that
he assaulted her brother.
They showed the video and
that's what got him off.
So I think that she's obviously
a crazy person and would lie,
but I think that's normal
for people to beat your ass.
Like people that beat your ass like that,
like physically beat your ass
to fucking crazy. They're crazy.
Of course they're going to lie. They're
telling the truth. They're fucked up.
There are a mess. Like that's gotta be
the hardest thing about being a cop.
He's like,
you're showing up and two people are
beating the fuck out of each other.
You've got to figure out who did what.
And you always got to side with
the woman who Scott Simpson law.
It's what they nicknamed. And the
reason why you get aside with a woman,
it's cause it's like,
let's reverse that scenario.
If that guy had been beating that girl
up, it wouldn't be funny at all. Right.
But it was funny to me watching that guy.
Yeah. To me while he's Selfie, come on.
I think that's funny.
I would not think it's funny if it
was a man doing it to a woman. Right?
Because I would worry the
woman's going to really get hurt.
I wasn't worried about him
getting hurt there. I mean,
she wasn't even strong enough to hurt
him. You never know man. He was only 17
I was a grown adult like selfie himself,
probably a grape timid.
She wanted to know. I think that kid
is smart that he didn't fight back.
I just very smart and it'll, all he
did was defend himself. Very smart.
He's a smart kid, obviously. She can't
just go around doing that like, yeah,
you probably shouldn't fucking fly your
drone in to people's houses can film
them. You shouldn't hover
over their backyard with a
trying to Suntan and filling
them. I don't know what he was doing
this, it's a weird thing. This,
this idea that you could put a camera
on top of a little like robot and fly it
around because when we were
filming that Scifi show,
we had some dudes that
were really good at it.
They had like these high tech drones
and we were fucking around with them and
putting on these goggles and
the virtual reality goggles.
You put them on and you feel like
you're flying like this drone,
you're going over the tree tops and I
was like this is going to get real weird
cause this isn't super expensive stuff
like you're looking at this, this is like,
I mean I don't know a couple thousand
bucks or something like that to get a rig
like this. I don't know. I
don't know how many thousand.
I'm just guessing but it didn't look
to be like prohibitively expensive.
It's not like something that costs
50 grand or something like that.
I think you could get it for the price
of some toys that people save up and buy.
Like there's a lot of people that can
have a fucking flying robot that films
everything now they have it
at Fry's for like 30 bucks.
Really cheap.
Well I don't know.
Technology is crazy when that's like
in the eye on the checkout area,
on your way out. Grab a drone. I
don't think it's the same thing.
Level of sophistication that these
guys had. These guys had, like I said,
virtual reality cameras attached to 'em
and they're pretty sophisticated but
they have a real problem with how
long they can stay up in the air.
They can't stay up in the air very
long. They just, they just can't do it.
They're just the out of gas and they fall.
You could load them up with batteries
but then that batteries is weight and it
makes it harder for them to fly so they,
they need to work around that.
I think they can only stay up for like
30 minutes or something like that.
Maybe there's some that can do it better,
but when you're watching one fly over the
tree tops and you wearing one of those
goggles, it's a trip, dude. It's a
freaky feeling. You're like, wow,
this is nuts. This is like what
it's like to be an eagle. You know?
They get that shit really, really
good. It's going to be nuts.
If they can develop some super clear,
like get some something that wraps
around your head, right? Like this,
like your entire field division
out like this is all this,
you know the screen and then figure out
some way to film something and not have
it make any noise so you
don't hear it. Right. You,
you somehow or another they can make
something that doesn't make noise.
Yeah. These drones, there's a really
cool music video or if not music video,
but just a video of a guy throwing,
doing a drone over Los Angeles and he
goes like on top of the capital records
building, you could see like the
roof and stuff like that. It,
he goes over like the
Hollywood hills parties.
Like that house that's above the comedy
store and there's people having a party
up there and he's just going right
over people with beach balls.
There's Jim Henson's a studios he just
flew over. See? That's weird. Yeah.
That's kind of weird.
Especially like say if you have like
an ex boyfriend or an ex girlfriend
beside the fucking fly,
a drone around your house and film you
while you're fucking the next person
you know, get mad at you,
you fucking piece of shit.
You didn't even wait a month,
wasn't expecting you to be
watching me with your drone.
Drone introduced me to the truth.
You're a piece of shit.
Fucking deflect deflecting.
When I bought you the drone,
I didn't think you were
going to be spying on me.
I thought you'd trust me like
the arguments of the future.
Do you think
speed used by like perverts and Papa
razzies nowadays like just going up in
hotels with little cameras and
drones and stuff. Cause look at this.
This is like HD. Look at this
party that's on top of this hotel.
Look at these people are just having a
party in and it's drones flying over.
People start noticing the journey to
start throwing like beach balls at it and
stuff. They made in certain places where
it's legal to shoot them in Colorado.
There was a town in Colorado that past
some sort of a resolution that allow you
to shoot at drones. Wow. That's so,
yeah. It's going to be like a video game.
We're going to have be like shooting
drones everyday. Here's comminsure.
Look about going above the comedy
store. I've been there. Yeah.
Top of the,
this uh,
Colorado town.
Apparently they're just considering it.
They haven't done it totally as
of March 31st but it's deer trail,
Colorado and uh,
there's 563 people in the town.
They're worried about it.
You should be worried about
getting it up to 600 people.
You're fucking town as tiny as shit.
Your town isn't even a small theater.
That's ridiculous.
How do you guys have your own laws?
That seems preposterous that a town that
little like you driving through and the
law changes and then you go to the
other side, the law's different.
Get the fuck out of here. The law is
different in that you've got 563 people.
That's a cult. Okay. That's
a cult. You got a call.
You do not have a town.
You fucking Weirdos.
They probably just made
it legal for witches.
All right.
We'll allow witchcraft for now.
But those drones are the devil.
Robot
drove my bridging those
flying robot, which is out of
here on their flying robot.
Broomstick.
Well there's these two
towns in Colorado. One is Greeley
and one is a right next to it.
I kind of can't remember the
name of the one next to it.
Deer valley or some shit, whatever
it is. The one next to it,
it braced we'd like in a big way where
they're just got fucking dispensary's
opening up everywhere and giant
warehouses have right next to it.
There's Greeley,
Colorado and they had the CNBC show and
it was hilarious because they had this
guy who was like the sheriff of Greeley
who wouldn't allow it and it was like,
you know, I'm telling you,
there's been a lot of things.
I shows you 80 with marijuana now.
Like we're noticing long
term psychiatric issues,
but her habit and you listened to this
guy talk and he's like some old fucking
cowboy, right? Some crazy old cowboy who
doesn't realize the war is over. Yeah.
The fucking the guys like standard.
Well, you're, no, no, no. Psych,
psychiatric issues. What
about booze? You Fuck?
What about cigarettes and the
beatings you took in the boxing gym?
Should all that be illegal? You fucking
crazy asshole. Look at these people.
They're having a blast right next
door. Go over to that place. Go,
go check out what they're doing.
They're fucking dancing.
This treat and hugging each other.
Everybody's high as fuck.
They're making millions. They're
making millions and you're like, well,
your bum loan. Oh, the
psychological issues due to marrow.
There's no psychological issues
due to fucking playing cards. Okay.
People are nuts. We don't, we're not
perfect. The idea that weed is the one,
what's the fucking sending these
psychological issues, people over the top.
How dare you?
How dare you make that association?
Especially since you know, stress is
such a huge factor of psychologic shit.
The number, it has to be the number one
cause of psychological issues. Stress.
Not to mention physical people don't
really realize the reason why hearts give
out is because of stress.
That's all the years of stress.
I mean, yeah, you get old,
but it's still stressed.
Stress on the heart and stress stress.
So it's so funny that that's a stance
like marijuana causing psychological
issues when,
well the problem Tony Hinchcliffe
with your kind of thinking needs,
we have data to back up our assertions.
It shows a clear change in the human
brain we hear is the area that accepts
bullshit shrinks. Okay, we
need that plump and fat,
but that area is not like fog. Why? We
need it like, like off filled sponge.
That's what we need.
That the area that allows bullshit and
the marijuana is shrinking this area that
allows you to tolerate bullshit and I
don't like it. I don't, I do not like it.
We need people out there that can do,
could just suck in our bullshit and pro.
It's like a bullshit liver. That's what
it is. You'll give a bullshit liver,
liver for booze.
You also have a bullshit liver in your
brain and marijuana apparently makes it
thing shrink.
That's what I heard.
Wow. They try everything. They've
tried it, they try everything.
This scare marijuana smokers.
Why? Why is that? They should just
smoke weed and get their dick sucked.
They would change the way they feel
about all this. They'd be like,
I can't believe blowjobs feel so good,
dude. Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude,
dude.
It's from someone who loves you.
Who tickles your balls when
you come in their mouth? Hey,
while you're high Jesus Louisa's okay.
They don't know about that.
Did they know about that?
Cause if they do, you know,
I would imagine if you're a way the
sheriff at Greenlee knows about that.
If you're a girl and you smoke a couple
of hits a weed and then get your pussy
licked,
that's kind of feels so good.
Could you imagine like a shower
feels good when you're high,
you can imagine how good it feels for
girl. Do you like your ass licked?
Do I like my ass? Like, yeah, listen.
Hi.
How are you never going to
have this conversation right
now then is here is here
with you?
I'm not opening those doors.
What kind of a man asks another man?
This is like a fill out form for
a fucking gang bang video. Okay.
Now do you like getting your ass luck?
Because if yes,
checked the box to the right,
that should never come up.
You should go from you cradle to the
grave without anybody ever asking you do
you like it in your ass lights,
right?
Or maybe maybe that should be it.
That should be a fun thing about a funeral
is you have to write the answer yes
or no, like on a piece of paper and then
have it in your hand. Like when you're
like in the open casket,
I secretly love you.
Did you check his note? That was the
yes, with two exclamation points.
He really like
the problem with the question.
Do you like your ass is that's
not how anybody ever asks it.
If they're going to lick your ass right.
They don't go.
Do you like to get your ass looked?
They don't say that.
They would say do you want me to
lick your ass? Huh? You do. Huh?
They would have a lot of hugs in there.
Like you want me to look your ass? Huh?
You do?
Huh?
Like they're already affirming it
cause it's a risky thing to say like,
you want me to lick your ass?
Huh? Let me try it again, Joe.
This is an affirmation in it. You
know, it's like you, you want to,
we want that person to have
an easy time saying yes,
you want me to look at your ass and
you go, well that would be cool.
You fucking sick.
Fuck fuck you like checked you asshole.
Right, right. The bedroom opens
up, the camera crew comes in,
you've been on the new show, do you want
your ass hole? And then it becomes, sounds
like a big court case where
they try to figure out what the,
what ha means when you add hod to it
and then the lawyer tries to defend it
clearly if she used
the word, Huh? She was,
she was trying to get a
positive affirmation out of him.
She was manipulating
his emotional responses,
the natural responses of a person.
He was doing it to be polite.
You didn't really want
his ass select okay.
He didn't want her to feel bad and she
said, ha already. It's like, yeah, okay.
What as it was happening, he was
realizing he had made a mistake. You know,
it'd be like joining an army that thinks
they're going to go out and fight big
foot. Like you got all your fucking gear
and you're ready to go to the mountains.
Like we are the Sasquatch.
And He'd be like, Oh, what
have I done? What have I done?
I can't believe I'm going to go. This
is an army of people I've joined. Fuck,
I made a mistake.
Shit be can't pull out of it.
That's what it's gotta be like.
It's crazy.
Poor guy, Greeley, Colorado.
It put bastard right next door.
I forget what the other cities name.
Is that the, is that the same place that
shoots down the drones? Is there, is it
no different place, but the, the
other place, the name, they were,
those people were so high that I forgot
their name. That's how high they were.
Like the mayor of the town
was joking around about it.
They had the mayor of the town and this
interview start joking around about this
town's always been like that. Like
Greeley was at drive town back in the day.
He couldn't get booze.
We don't want no booze because what
we see you and we have tenants in the
church. That's a bunch of crazy
people. That's what that is.
A lot of hooting and hollering.
The reason why they're
afraid of booze and pot,
if they're that afraid of it is because
they're afraid. What they'll do with,
they have a drink or a smoke.
They're afraid that that inner monster,
whatever their fears and whatever crazy
stuff's going on, that's what that is.
Well, no, no, no. Tony Hinchcliffe,
I'm worried about your inner monster
cause my inner monster is safe under the
guidance of the Lord.
So you're a heathen out there running
around with your own ideas and I got
children. Okay, Tony Hawk,
I have bad news for you.
You're going and praying to an
imaginary creature once or twice a week.
You fucking communists,
lesbian asshole.
Listen, you can't say that it's imaginary.
You don't know you son of a bitch.
I go to church, I feel the Holy
Spirit inside of me all the time.
I moved to tongues. You haven't
moved to tongues, Tony Hinchcliffe,
then your priest, he drinks wine. I
mean Jesus turned water into wine.
You don't want to, I'm going to get your
athletic, sir. I'm a baptist. Baptist.
We don't, we don't fuck around with
wine. You can't have wine in the church.
That's true. They don't drink
wine. I don't believe so.
I think the wine is a Catholic thing.
Let's find out. It was a Google day.
Do Baptist use one? Hmm. I
know the Catholics love wine
nature. They try any excuse
like, Hey, can we get the,
well, you know what's really funny? Um,
Mormons are not supposed to drink coffee,
but they can drink those
energy drinks. I'm sorry. I do
like, dude, he was a Mormon.
Well you sell pound those fucking giant
monster energy drinks and the dude would
have panic attacks all the time. It was
just jack to the teeth all day. Just
red lining it all day.
This gives me, he has no idea
cause never having coffee. Right.
He wouldn't drink the coffee, but yet
he's pounding. Is it an evil being right?
There was an evil being out there and
it's corrupt in the souls of red bull
gives me wings. Just like the angels have
more. Exactly. Exactly. Mormon religion.
A drink, a monster energy drink to
be a Munster against Satan's urges.
Monstrously attack you.
Nothing funnier than Mormonism.
There is, you know the,
when they think that when you die, you
get your own planet. You know that, right?
Um, how do you know you don't Tony?
Hinchcliffe. Okay. Why so judgmental,
Tony Hinchcliffe and that everybody lives
on their own different planet and then
like, well yeah, it'd be dope,
but that's a made up story.
It's only dope. If we could visit
each other. I can wait. Sorry.
Like you were on the moon and I was
on Mars, but I couldn't get to you.
I'd be like, Tony, where are
you? But I'm sure in this world,
like traveling is like just so fast.
Yeah.
It's probably pretty quick if you can
get to a place where you have your own
planet.
I assume you just be wherever you want.
Whenever you want to be there
instantaneous. That'll happen one day.
We'll figure that out. We'll be
figuring out how to transport ourselves.
If human beings live for another
million years, if we live,
we're supposedly like
this close to like this,
this frame that we're in right now,
the Homosapien, the way we look,
it's supposedly pretty similar to what
a million years ago. It looked like,
like a million years ago. There was
some [inaudible] man kind of stood up,
but fairly similar, you know, and
then maybe in this form, you know,
a few hundred thousand years, three
or 400,000 years. Like I said,
there's a lot of guesswork
involved and figured it out.
But if we could keep going another
million, we would be hairless for sure.
We'd lose our hair.
We would probably be really slight
and very Tony Hinchcliffe like like a
dancer's Physique and alien
dancer and I heads would grow.
We would look like fucking aliens
and then hit. We hit that point.
If we continue,
if we don't blow each other up,
if we continue and we don't
get hit by an asteroid,
we continue to improve our ability
to do things. We'll, it'd be nuts.
A million years from now, you probably
will be able to transport any or teleport
anywhere you want anywhere in the world.
I want up yet,
I'll bet a hundred thousand
years at this rate,
he's Tony Hinchcliffe at this rate
that we're growing with technology.
I think we're even closer.
I would almost say 10,000 years,
thousand years ago, that sounds
really dumb, but if 10,000 years ago,
it doesn't seem like that long ago,
but that's a really long,
like 10,000 years ago,
we find these like stone buildings that
they made a bunch of really cool shit
that they left behind,
but not much else.
Dozen years ago.
I don't even think people are on boats.
They didn't even figure that out yet.
They did
there.
They're finding out that people figured
out a lot of shit a lot earlier than we
thought. In fact, 40,000
years ago they were hunting.
There were a fishing for tuna and boats,
which is pretty cool.
Pretty sure that was the number that they
came up with cause they found these uh,
these deep sea rigs,
you know,
whether you use these long lines and at
these big hooks and they were catching
tuna and they found tune in DNA,
which is really crazy.
Like tuner deep water fish. So these
fuckers, let me find out what year it was.
They figured out,
let me see.
What would Google their ancient people
fish for tuna. A sitting on a yoga ball.
Now know what it is. That
chair. It's interesting.
It's a fuck back support. Who needs
it? No, this is this the best um,
back support was for me at least it
forces you to stand, sit straight.
Like see how I'm sitting. Like this
is how you're supposed to set, right.
You're supposed to sit like this. Like
your head's not supposed to be forward.
And when you,
most times you sit in the chair,
you wind up slumping sitting like that
and then it makes your back really tight.
Since I've been using this, my back
never fucks with me when we do podcasts.
That's awesome. Yeah, you just, you,
you sit on it and your knees are in it.
I don't know what they're called,
like a new chair or something like that,
but you just,
you're,
you're carrying your own weight and
then once you do it for a while,
if you get used to it,
then he started doing it everywhere.
Like I do it on planes, I do it and you
should sit up straight like all the time.
And when you don't, when you have bad
posture, I used to think that people said,
Oh, you should watch your
posture because it like,
they didn't want you to look in lazy,
but it's actually not good for your discs.
Like your,
your shit gets compressed.
That's why I wouldn't
do to have a fat wallet.
They say never keep a fat wallet in your
back pocket if you're one of those guys
that keeps every God damn business
car that you ever get when we're sad,
broken toys r us $10 off you,
you get these big fat, crazy
thick wallets. If you sit
on that shit all the time,
you can get disc problems.
Like a lot of cab drivers get psychotic
nerve problems because they get a pinch
disk because your body's just got an
uneven distribution of weight and that's
what it is. Kind of when
you're slumped or sit in weird,
you know it's an uneven
distribution of weight.
I have that 100% anytime I go on a
road trip now after like two hours,
my right side gets starts getting numb
and I start, I start having like little,
do you sit on your wallet?
No I don't,
but it's like how I sit and also
my max lunch or I'm a turtle.
Yeah,
you shouldn't do that man.
I used to think that it was
just that like slouching. I,
I had a real problem with slouching. I
slouch all the time and I just, I think,
I thought it was just like
the way it looks is not good,
but people don't like the way it looks
like. So my attitude was, fuck man,
let's go. So stupid. But
it's just not your, when you,
when your back is straight like this,
like this is the way you're not,
you're supposed to stand your,
your spinal column,
your core is carrying your weight
very evenly. It's all stacked up.
But when you're head goes
forward and you sort of relax,
you put a great deal of pressure
on other parts. You put like, uh,
there's like a peak area of your
spine that has additional pressure,
it seems like nothing and it is nothing
for a long time and then it becomes
something.
And if you sit like I used to get real
bad back and neck pains from writing and
I think I might've fucked myself up
doing that as much as I fucked myself up
from doing Jujitsu.
Cause I would write for a long period
of time and I would sit in a chair like
this when my head forward and then
when I was all done I'd be like, ah,
my neck would be fucking killing me.
I just don't like sitting like this
cause I feel like I'm like posing like a
woman and I'm sure he correctly
pointed my button boobs.
I feel like I have to like look back
at it like I hate it or something.
So you're afraid of what the way it looks.
You'd rather just have a backache.
Right. You know, a backache. It's just
easier to deal with. But seriously,
it does look really silly
for me to sit like, hey,
cause I mean my butt's sticking
out, my sticking out. Like
I feel like, uh, well you
need to reduce both of them.
That would help tremendously.
And
that's Brian Redbill. Right? Totally.
I don't want to lose my, my
boobs and my butt. Uh, you know,
I've been working on this. So he lost
a lot of weight and got real slim.
It's like, it makes my head look too big.
Fuck. And he's just kind of like a free
spin. All this work to get down
to like 160 something pounds.
He was like super skinny.
Yeah.
I have a picture of me and you together
and I looked like a fucking lego boy.
She don't look like a Lego boy,
dude. You just, you look healthy.
I look like at an aids.
Remember everyone called me aids
so quick. You did. It's not everyone.
You're at the post office and drop
off some packages. Okay. AIDS face.
Alright, you aids face. Yeah. Starbucks.
Venti Mocha Latte. AIDS face.
Okay. They write it on your cup.
It didn't look like he had aids.
Dude,
what it looked like to me was a guy
who lost weight. He looked healthy.
That's when we met Seth
Rogen. That's right. Yeah.
We did the high times music awards.
What is it? High Times awards.
I presented him with stoner of the
year and there was Jack [inaudible],
Jack hair or hair or when he was alive
back then. Those things are interesting.
Those fucking high times awards.
She meet all of the fellow stoners,
not maybe the nicest people on the planet,
like celebrity stoners, like be real.
Is there a nicer person
and be real that guys,
one of the nicest people on the
planet and all those celebrities,
stoners and all like super
cool. Doug Benson, sweetheart,
you know? Yeah, I'll just,
all the celebrities,
stoners are just super nice people.
Why anybody would want to stop a
drug like that? Well, you know,
I'll tell you the problem with that.
Well,
you're not taking into account as
a lack of ambition. You stoners,
they did take up, you know, a lot of room
and they don't do anything. They don't,
they don't earn their keep it.
Sheriff.
What about all the artists and the
musicians that have come from my pot smoke
pot? You mean queers like Steve Jobs?
Is that you're just trying to say? Yeah,
Jesus took him from us. Let me tell
you something. Jesus not impressed.
He didn't do you know what? It
looked like? AIDS face there.
You look good and it looked like no,
you're just not used to it cause you're
used to this backup. You saw the support,
you got your head and then he got some
backup. When you're potty shrinks up,
you felt like you didn't have any backup.
Your head just didn't.
Aw, Brian. Dude, you don't
look bad there at all.
You look great. You want to have
sex. You know I've told you before.
Why does everything that skinny
with you mean gay? That's so weird.
This has got issues.
I just looked like I had aids.
You don't look like you have aids. HIV.
You don't even look again for each of it.
You'll get diarrhea like a little
bit like you got to that phase,
dude. Come on, look at that
picture. You don't look at all,
it's the dude from weeds. But look at
your face. You do not look bad at all.
I couldn't, I can't watch weeds.
I watched one episode and um, uh,
who the fuck was on it? One
of our, our friends was on.
Oh, uh, who was on it? Kevin Nealon.
Bright Ernst Brennan or
answers all. Yes. Right.
What did he play like a drug dealer
drug dealer. And I watched it
is Bret was on it. That's it. I watched
it one of the time when I was like,
this is fake. This is not
real. Not buying them.
No,
it's fake is that catfish show.
I heard so many people to say how
awesome that show is. I finally watch it.
The fake his show I've ever seen. I
didn't know it was fake. You know?
I heard on reality TV sometimes
they like playing that shit out,
like it's not really reality.
Did you hear that Tony? Well,
it almost seems like it would benefit them
with so much money. Spending money on,
wait a minute. Conspiracy
Theorists, the would,
they would do two just to make money,
willing to fake it and
risk their reputations on.
That's a reality show. When I tune
into a reality show, I want reality.
You know that and I know that. That's
a weird one to fake though. You know,
that is just fucking pizza.
Best one to fit all that.
They couldn't really figure out how
easy it is, like what they're doing.
Like people just looking at a camera
like I thought for sure that he was,
you know,
the man that I thought
did, people will do whatever
the fuck you asked them to do.
If you have a camera in front of you,
I mean there's a certain amount
of people that will do it.
So if you have some sort of reality show
and you just manipulate these people
and say, Hey, I want you to,
this is what you're going to do.
Are you going to tell us they know that
you been texting this guy and pretending
to be a girl and then you're gonna
meet him here and say, I busted you do.
Now I know what's up. And the
guy's like, okay, okay. Okay.
How long have I known him? You've been
friends for 20 years. Okay, okay, okay.
We've been friends for 20 years, men
and they'll say shit like that, man.
We'd been friends for 20 years.
I thought I trusted you.
Of course they going to fit all that
Maury Povich and stuff like that.
That shows still when I'm on the road
and I'm flipping through channels,
I'll stop for a few minutes
and I'll watch Maury, I'll,
I'll watch the results because no
matter what, no matter what happens,
one of them is going to get
up and go, oh, I told you,
I told you that that was or wasn't
my baby. Like whichever one,
one of them's going to flip out because
they, you know, it's just so coached.
She was a doorman at, um, uh, not
east side comedy club, governors,
governors in Levittown in Long Island.
And one of the doorman was a regular
on those shows back in the day. Like,
this is the 19,
I want to say 1990,
1991 pre internet. And he used
to get a call and they would say,
we're looking for a man who has been
having sex with his brother's wife.
And he goes, what a coincidence. I've
been having sex, my brother's wife,
what do you want me to do? And
they would, they would you,
they would literally say that to him,
see if you can help us out here.
That was the conversation that would have,
what we're trying to find is a guy who
got arrested wearing women's clothes,
trying to get a job in a woman's office
and they go, oh, what a coincidence. That,
you know, they'll tell him the
exact scenario that he wants.
So all those people are just,
they're just good at it.
You'll see the Mike Rekha did it.
Mike Rekha did it way back in the day.
Mike Ricco,
who was a comic at the comedy store in
the 1990s he did that Shit for money.
I met Mike. Yeah. Mike is Funny Dude,
man. Mike was a funny dude. You know,
I don't know if he's still doing stand
up anymore, but back in the day when we,
we started out together at the store
in the 90s he was fucking funny man.
There's a lot of those guys that
for whatever reason, you know,
people don't find out about them.
Yeah.
He's one of those guys that was there
the first a few months when I started and
we like made friends and then I watched
him basically quit. Yeah. I mean, I, he,
I know, I think he moved
somewhere else, but I, you know,
I watched him fade out of the store.
Yeah. But anyway, he used to do that
shit. They would hire him to do,
like I remember when,
um,
what was the chick Jenny Jones was that
it that check whether the show remember
and they,
they did a thing where they humiliated
this guy because there was a gay guy that
he worked with that was a
in love with him. And so he,
the guy comes on and uh,
he has no idea that this gay guy
loves them and he freaks out.
He gets humiliated on the show and then
he goes and shoots the guy afterwards
and they were like,
that's a wrap for you.
And they just cease and desist the
entire show. But that show was a,
that was a turning point. And
those things, they realize, okay,
this isn't fucking repercussions to the
shit like you guys are. But in that,
that's when stuff started getting more
produced. Like they realize that exist.
They got to tell the person before,
right? Yeah. When they
did the Jenny Jones thing,
that was a real guy and a real office
who was attracted to his coworker.
And when that guy was on TV with them,
this nutty dude,
he wound up shooting the guy. You know,
he was just humiliated beyond words.
But where's like if you were on there and
you found out some guy at work thought
you were hot, you'd be uncomfortable,
but he would, he would find it hilarious.
Right. And you would, you'd probably
have an issue cause dudes can get creepy.
And you know,
if you were a girl,
you got on a show and you found
out that your coworker loves you,
there'll be a real problem.
You know, if you a girl,
say if you worked in some office,
maybe even have a boyfriend or a
husband and you got some guy who's your
coworker who not only
professors his love to you,
but does so on national television in
a surprise attack. Yeah. You'd be like,
oh great,
now I got to fucking stop working there
or he's going to stop working there or
something's gonna happen.
Yeah. It is a weird approach,
especially when you factor in that.
That guy probably told the gay guy,
probably told the guy on Jenny Jones on
the air so that nothing would happen to
him. You know? He didn't tell him at the
office like, hey man, I really like you.
Please don't hit me.
He went on the air and that backfired.
Yeah. I guess he probably thought, look,
I'm going to be on TV with the fucking
is going to happen to me. All right.
I'm going to be on television. Nothing
can happen. It's not going to hurt me.
No one's going to hurt me. Jen
on television. Yeah. Jenny Jones.
Careers just going to keep going on.
The show's going to keep going.
Everything's going to be fine.
Jim Jones is a talent. Yeah. Okay.
You're not going to stop her with
one little scandal. Right. It's
going to be back stronger than ever.
America demands change. John's. Yeah. She
used to have a show that she would do.
She was a comic. Oh Wow. I didn't
know she used to have, yeah,
she used to do a show back in the day.
If you go to Jenny Jones,
like the early stuff, it's crazy cause
she had this crazy but bulletproof hairdo,
these big giant like huge sprayed up
hairdo and she would do these ladies only
shows. And when I was living in
Boston, there was a club, uh,
I don't know if it was the
Kami connection or it was,
it was either duck soup or the improv
because it was the upscale there.
They had an upscale club and she would a
buy out every seat and there was no men
who are allowed in the building.
The, the guys couldn't work.
The bar guys couldn't work the door. They
had to have like all female employees,
females in the whole thing
would be filled with females.
And so they did it as
sort of like a gimmick.
And they had these all female shows with
Jenny Jones and talk about her period.
Wow.
Or whatever
men stuff were things that men
want to hear. That's, but that's a,
the when the guy fucked with
her or that's when the, um,
the guy I fucked with the
other guy rather, and uh,
told them that he was in love with them.
But if you go back to her stand up,
you'll see her crazy hair. When,
when they had her on the talk show,
she kind of toned it down and her
hair became like normal sized. Yeah.
But before it was like some tribal thing
she had before she was on TVs. Yeah.
She has like some trouble
peacock thing going on. Oh yeah.
There's network head. Say, oh, we're going
to put you in hair and makeup. No, no.
Stan is that stand up. Yeah. She
supposedly on this Ferris guys,
look at that POW man.
Good Lord.
It's like David Bowie. That's
like rock stars here. Some of it.
He's a good eye doctor though.
And she's hot.
Yeah,
Mr. Jokes around the country. I feel
like kind of a spokesperson for women.
I think men should listen to me. I think
you guys can learn something really.
You wanna know what I find
attractive on a man? Cash.
Okay.
I hate you. Wear the
tight wise. Where are you?
She looks like the top half of a sentence
and see what clothes looked like in
the 60. [inaudible] the way she's
moving cause she's on those heels.
It's just a balancing at
dinner at the sizzler.
He forgot the coupons.
We had to go back.
Oh my God. This is, they've
got an applause break.
Stop this. Stop this right now.
This is CGI. CGI The king car.
That's better. Sees you as a dire wolves
and game of Thrones. That's ridiculous.
There's nothing worse than a fake
applause. Break like a bad one. Well,
I mean the navy really loved her
and we're so happy to hear it.
Just get out of joke.
Oh you saw the movie punchline right?
With oh I tried to watch it the other
day and just see if there was like,
there was parts in it that I remember
going. That was the, that was hilarious,
but in the wrong reason. Yeah. Yeah. Well
that was before you did stand up. Right.
And that was also like 10
when it came out. Yeah, I
was, um, I was doing
standup when that came out.
Like I was just starting to do stand
up and I remember watching going,
what the fuck is this?
This is crazy. Like it's,
it's weird when you watch someone do
something that you know they can't do.
Like if I was ever gonna
like say if I did a movie,
I'll never do a movie that
you'll have to play guitar.
But if I did a movie where
I played guitar in it,
I would learn how to fucking play guitar.
Okay.
Cause if I was a guitar player and I
was watching some movie about Jimmy
Hendrickson, the guy's
just like, all right,
no, he doesn't know what he's doing. He's
just moving his fingers around. Yeah,
I would,
I would be like this is annoying
shit. I know he can't really play
guitar. This guy is faking it.
Like if you watch him like some fake
Kung Fu in a movie, it's very good.
It ruins the movie for you. Right. That's
why like in kill bill ever see that? Oh,
you're a Tino sent everybody in that
assassination squad to Japan for like a
month or two or three. Some crazy amount
of time. Learn. Kendo, learn all of it.
They learn the art of the Samurai Sword.
They learned a Kung Fu.
I mean big time like
from the guys for what?
Main people from the actual
old school stuff. Well,
you know David Lee Roth does that now.
David Lee Roth lives in Japan and Take
Samurai lessons. That sounds awesome.
That sounds amazing to Japan with his dog
by himself.
Got An apartment and he takes Kendo.
Kendo is this Japanese sword fighting
and he practices sword fighting.
That's so cool. Yeah. David
Lee Roth is a legit maniac.
He said, well, he's wild man.
You know, doesn't give a fuck.
Having a great time doing Kendo.
Playing sword fighting. One of the
biggest rock stars the world's ever known.
And you knew those
Japanese people lose it.
If he comes into like their restaurant,
it's a bit of a
jump jump.
Go ahead and jump.
I bet not.
I bet he sleeps links right in. You
know, because he dresses very low key.
Like he wears overalls all the time
and like one of them paper Boi hats.
He wears one of those things all the time.
So He's, I bet he just slinks around.
It's gotta be so beautiful over
there and Japanese, Japanese culture.
So smooth and relaxing and cool.
It's very different. That's for sure.
That's one of the reasons why Japan,
if you go over there,
it feels like you're in another world.
It doesn't just feel like
you're in another country.
It feels like you're in another world.
Like the way people behave,
like everybody's like really
polite. It's, it's very unusual.
They don't necessarily like white people,
especially the old folks that were
around like during the Pearl Harbor days.
You know, not, not a big fan of
white folks when it comes to that,
but the rest of them, the young
kids love Americans, young people.
I guess most of those Pearl
Harbor people were dead.
But how could you expect it
to not hate on Americans?
They dropped two bombs on
them where the, yeah, we
messed up. We, yeah, we did that. That was
sort of an ouchie. That was a big ouch.
That's a such a dick move.
Billy is,
I mean we are the only people in the
world to really nuke another place. Right.
We'd go to twice to do it once.
Sure.
They weren't just shitty buildings.
Let's try
the other one. Yeah, no, I think it was
the next day or something like that.
Oh, oh, it was, you know, there's
one guy, because I read a thing.
Here's one that's crazy for me. I read
a thing about the guy that was in both,
he was in Hiroshima, right. And
uh, he had to like go to work.
Like he barely survived or whatever was
on a train or something like that to
Nagasaki.
So he goes from here,
she survives Hiroshima
and Nagasaki the next day.
And then same thing happens.
Imagine the luck on that
guy. God, that's crazy.
That's crazy.
And just imagine that time of the year
or that time of the world when you really
could just think that this could continue.
Like bombs could just be dropping now.
Like once we started,
we were in the middle of a world war
and then all sudden cities are getting a
level, like a whole city is
getting leveled. Hmm. I mean
how many people died? Those
a lot.
And you know,
another thing is that the one in
Hiroshima landed next to a hill.
So like the hill actually
saved a lot of people.
The,
okay.
The atomic bomb killed between 90 and
166,000 within the first two to four
months,
roughly half of the deaths in each city
occurred on the first day during the
following month's large numbers died
from the effects of the burns, radiation,
sickness and other injuries
compounded by illness. In both cities,
most of the dead were civilians,
although Hiroshima had a sizable garrison.
Wow.
Crazy.
Oh,
we got a shooter of the day
shooting at Oregon high school to
confirmed dead. Oh, that's today.
Yeah. Just now. Jesus Christ. Oh.
Or what the hell is going on?
Do you think it's getting going to
become where we all have to have guns.
We all have to carry guns.
Just like star wars where we all
have our weapons all the time.
All of us are going to
be one or the other.
Either it's going to be that or
it's going to be no guns. Right?
August 6th was Hiroshima. August
9th was Nagasaki. So they waited.
They waited a couple of days. God,
it's so scary. Yeah, yeah. Bold.
That's what the gun people are worried
about the gun people worried about.
You know,
they're just going to try and take our
guns away now and people are not going to
just give up their guns and they're going
to vote for people that are going to
be putting an offense. They're getting
sure that you don't put up their guns.
And then the problem is those people
also get connected. Like if you,
if you have a guy like say there's a
guy that says I am going to support the
second amendment, no matter what. Every
American has a right to bear arms.
Everybody goes crazy. All the bear
arms, people are on that guy side now.
So that guy,
you can attach that guy to a bunch of
other shit you might not necessarily
believe in.
Like you get attached to that guy to
a bunch of weird environmental shit
relaxing some of the environmental
regulations that are on certain areas that
are a bit risky to do certain things in
that might kill a bunch of fucking weird
fish. But whatever, whatever,
we can make a lot of money.
There's those guys get
attached and corrupted in a
attached to all those things
because you know that there's a sizeable
chunk of Americans that will vote to
keep their guns.
And then there's also the people that are
on the other side of it that you know,
they'd look, they'd, no matter what,
they're going to vote against guns.
There's no matter what.
Like if you, if you're,
we got to clean up these streets and
take these guns out of these schools,
you hush. There's those people
and you've got those people.
If you are an anti gun person, you
say, we need tighter regulations,
we need tighter restrictions. We
need less guns, not more gone.
You have those people. So, and then you
can attach that to a bunch of weird shit.
It'd be weird social shit insurance
company scams where everybody has to get
certain amounts of insurance and it kept,
can we swap my Omar,
how about we have a,
everybody has to wear your seatbelt
because we were paying out too much money.
So they have regulations to protect you.
You have to wear a seatbelt.
Well if I have to wear a seatbelt,
how come this guy is allowed to
drive a motorcycle? Are you crazy?
He doesn't even have a cage around him.
Like this doesn't make any sense. Okay.
You make them wear help.
Congratulations. Make them wear helmets.
I think it's way safer for me
in a car with no seatbelt on.
And I'm not trying to argue for no
seat belts cause I always wear one.
But I think it's way it probably way
safer to be in a car with no seatbelt than
it is to be on a motorcycle
when there's an accident. Right.
And in a lot of states they don't even
have to wear a helmet. No, no, Colorado,
you don't, you don't have to in Vegas
either Ohio and that's a big one. Yeah,
I think, uh, there's a
few, there's quite a few.
I think it's because the
people that ride motorcycles,
they love that feeling so much
that they're like, fuck it.
I'm willing to risk my dead.
Imagine that is like the wearing
a condom of the motorcycle world.
It's like once you do it without one,
you're like fuck or that and that.
You're absolutely right.
But nowadays with such great technology
with Bluetooth and phones and stereos
and the helmets and stuff,
I think more people are actually wearing
helmets because it's bad ass to take a
phone call while you,
it's in your helmet. Yeah.
I don't know about that dude
because the type of dudes who um,
don't want to wear helmets, those
are like the Harley guys, you know,
whether they don't want,
they just want
their Bandanna floating in it and a
woman and a woman when her arms wrapped
around my waist, I'm free. I got my red,
white and blue. They interrupt her. Him.
Oh wait, is that a drone up in
the air? How much true maverick?
I'm not like those faggots out there
pretending. Okay. I'm a true maverick.
I vote Republican and I ride a motorcycle.
I'm a woman's,
got some long nails like scratch my back
and I feel them pulling on the leather.
My Mum,
my vest and my motorcycle club makes them,
we'll up inside thinking
about all my other brothers,
my brothers are out there on their metal
horses riding out into the sunset where
together we're a team.
We're a band of brothers.
I ride my back and I bear arms
and I got the arms of a bear.
Did you ever read a Hunter Thompson's
a thing on um, the motorcycle gangs?
He wrote his first book,
the big book that sort of introduced a
hundred Thompson to the world was his
take on the hell's angels.
He was embedded in the hell's angels,
like hung around with them, went with
them and he did it for a long time.
He was with like for a couple of years,
he was like embedded in the hell's angels
can go hang out with him at parties
and shit. But then, um,
he got into an altercation because the
guy was beating up his girlfriend and
hunter said something to him and the
guy beat the shit out of him too.
And a couple other guys beat
the shit out of them too.
And then he wrote the book, the book
came out and everybody fucking, you know,
went crazy for it.
And that sort of the started a
hunters Thompson's Gonzo journalism,
he went from that,
which is more of,
it's different if you compare it to his
other stuff. That's his first piece,
which is more, it's still got
that sort of Gonzo edge to it,
but it's more based in reality.
Then like when he did fear
and loathing in Las Vegas,
when he got the fear and
loathing in Las Vegas,
that was originally supposed
to be something that he
wrote for ESPN and it was a
covering like a motorcycle race. And
it was so fucking crazy that, you know,
they were like, we can't use this. And a,
he turned it into like this novel and
that sort of kick started his Gonzo career
that in Kentucky,
the Kentucky Derby,
he wrote a piece on the Kentucky Derby
that was pretty fucking crazy too. But he,
um,
he was embedded with those fucking angels
for two years and he's got some wild
fucking stories, man orgies.
And those guys would live,
would be like kiss each other whenever
they would have cameras on them.
They would kiss each other and telling
each other wow, freak people out.
Since these big motorcycle dudes,
crazy beards making out with each other,
wow.
Wasn't
why am ca,
where'd they get actually gay?
Because I saw a video the other day
and it didn't seem very gay village,
the village people and it's, but it
seemed like maybe one or two of them were,
but they,
uh,
do you remember,
do you remember Jamie Kennedy
when Jamie Kennedy had a,
that show the Jamie Kennedy
experiment or what was it?
Jamie [inaudible].
Was it the experiment? Yeah, he um,
he had this one episode that he did and
it was about guys and talk to these guys
into being strippers.
They're going to be male strippers
and then along why to get creepier and
creepier. Are they going to be on a
TV show? They're going to be there.
You're going to be able to like
girls gone wild guys gone nuts. Okay,
this guy's got nuts.
Hey, yeah. Okay, okay.
And then they tell them that it's going
to be, a lot of it is for gay guys,
but it doesn't matter man. You gotta
be a huge star and all that stuff.
And you know,
he starts like going over like some of
the gay things he might have to do like,
like money don't have to make out
with another man, might have to.
All the guys were like,
well man,
I don't want to do that but I do
want to be on the show. Damn. Um,
and then at the end of it they reveal.
But it's real. It's not a setup.
It was a real show. I mean Jamie
Kennedy's fucking genius in that Shit.
I don't know why he stopped doing that.
I mean maybe it was like lawsuits.
Maybe they got in trouble for doing it,
but that was like the best shit he
ever did. It was really fucking funny.
But it was all these guys.
So I would suspect that it's like
that kind of situation that if you,
there's this,
there's enough
guys out there that if
you just guaranteed them,
they're going to be on television,
guaranteed them to got to have some
sort of fame. They'll do some gay shit.
Well,
the reason why I ask,
cause I that something that
David or Eddie van Halen Shit.
David Lee Roth did I am a Gigolo
everywhere. I didn't know that.
Why am or a village people was one of
their songs and if you watch the video
it's smooth as hell. Like, like, like
he's a pimp and then, and that was like,
wait a second, I thought this was like,
like some weird like a gay band, you know,
do is type in,
are the village people and then yeah,
Google filled out.
Okay. Which members of the village people
were our gay. All right, here we go. Uh,
Victor Willis,
the policemen and Glenn Hughes.
The biker were straight while
pepe rose or Philippe rose,
the American Indian and Randy
Jones, the cowboy. David Hodo,
the construction worker and Alex
Briley military man were gay.
So there was only two straight dudes
and the rest of them were just for gay
members jerking off on them while they're
taking nuts. What is this? That's it.
This is just the Gigolo,
this guy.
This is a village people.
Wow. David Lee Roth.
You have a lot of explaining the,
but
it's actually like a kind of cool
video and I like, it's got like this,
I just changed my idea of what the
village people where you can really tell
which ones are gay.
Like this guy's just hooking up with a
chick and then it cuts to some guy with a
black tank top. And the pilots
had, well not only that,
it's a black guy and a white woman.
Yeah, the interracial vibe to it.
And she's really hot too.
Wow.
Oh there they were again.
They were all in the alley.
They cut to the gay guys dancing,
looking at themselves in the mirror. No,
the policeman was not gay.
The policemen and the biker or straight.
So that guy with the crazy mustache.
That's the biker, right? He's straight,
believe it or not.
Wow.
How's that possible hanging out
with too many gay guys hanging on?
I ain't got no,
that's hilarious
that the Indian is gay as fuck
though. See, I'm looking at
him dance. Look at that cowboy. You
can't tell me that cowboy straight.
I'll tell you that right now.
This is what,
you can't even dance like
that until you've had three
or four dicks in your ass.
It's not possible to move that away.
There's a looseness in his hips.
This is crazy. As the biker straight is,
fuck yeah. The bikers like, I am so proud.
They're going to pounce on me.
I'm just going to be so gay that
they don't even want a part of me.
That's what he's doing.
It's like, man, Halan.
Yeah, that mustache, that guy with the
mustache to assume you would have to be.
Oh, totally. Nope. That's,
wait. No, he's straight now.
He was in the closet.
Hey,
you're still in denial like I know
what you're talking about, man. I mean,
I just fucking, just a job,
bro. I'm just playing a biker.
Even if he's not gay.
His mustaches,
that mustache jumps off his face in the
middle of the night and goes and bangs
dudes
just comes back in the morning
smelling like liquor in, but oh,
holes in Bacardi
village.
People are great. I can get, Bro. Can
you imagine how insulted the Indians,
the Indians
representatives are quite pathetic
now to Cherokee nation voices is just
approval. Oh, that was an
Apache. Don't worry about it bro.
Those are the enemy anyway.
You know the Indians like they
didn't all like each other.
Did you guys know that? Oh yeah.
Fuck all the time. All the time.
The idea that like the white man came
and like there's a peaceful land.
They came the white man and
killed everyone I think.
And you guys were kind of killing
each other to the Lakota Sioux,
the Sioux Indian that the term sue
doesn't mean that's their name.
Like that means enemy. That's
what it means. They're,
they call themselves the Lakota people,
but the word sue is entity to the,
so these other native
tribes called them enemy.
Obviously the Americans and the Americans,
the white people.
Europeans did a way better job of killing
people and we're way more fucked up
about it and we're way more evil about
it and had guns and a lot of this shit,
but they didn't like each other
either. That's just people, man.
You never going to find like this idea
of you find this one piece for utopia
where everyone got along.
They were one with nature and they did
a lot of raping and killing to fucking
cut people up. They did a
lot of evil shit. They eight
people, so stop everybody.
There's no like one race
that you can go back and go.
Those fuckers had it nailed right.
Those guys were super cool to each other.
They had a balance civilization.
There was no murder, no rape,
no theft was never existed.
Definitely not.
We're a work in progress,
ladies and gentlemen and shit takes time.
The universe has been here for something
billion years. How many billions?
14 billion, something like
that. This planet's been
here four and a half billion.
4.6 something like that. I'm not
sure how long ass time. Okay.
We've been here for a million
years. If that. It takes time.
We've got to figure it out. So
no cultures ever had it. Right.
The idea that we should have left the
American Indians alone. Yeah. Great idea.
Fucking terrific. And then
what, and then what exactly.
They're there. All the village people,
it's just a bunch of Indians come on.
We needed to get some America seconds
in there. Yeah. Not only that,
like I'm not, um, I'm not,
I'm like arguing for genocide.
But that's happens when people go in,
they look at history, they look
at the positive benefits of like,
things that have happened that
were really ugly. Like when, uh,
like people talk about the
Mongols, they talk about how
the Mongols, uh, they, they,
they improve trade routes they
killed millions of people do though.
I mean they improve trade routes by
butchering like entire cities of people.
Yeah. They, things definitely started
moving more freely. But, but people like,
like to like look at the
positive benefits of like,
things like that were horrible.
Genocide took place.
So if you looked at like
Americans establishing
American Europeans coming over
and established American killing all
these native Americans, some people,
if they looked at it that way, would
say, well, if it wasn't for that,
we would never have Atlanta.
We would never have Miami.
We would never have these wonderful
cities that we eat enjoy today.
So in the long run it worked out. Yeah.
And the Indians, they have their casinos.
That's true.
They make a lot of money.
It's a pretty fucked up history when you
think about the history of the United
States.
Only a few hundred years ago,
there's these other folks that lived here
like only a few hundred years ago and
as many as like a million.
There was a lot of them at one point in
time there was a lot of fucking people
living in this country. Like the idea
that this place wasn't, wasn't populated.
Right. A lot of them, they killed
a lot of fucking people. Yeah.
They killed him in the crepe.
Creepiest ways to like putting,
they put smallpox in their,
their uh, their, their, their
blankets. Was it smallpox?
So they put in their blankets and gave
to these people. They put like blankets.
They had scabs in the blankets of people
that have diseases and they would put
it in the blankets and give them
to the American Indians. Oof. Oof.
Spreading these evil terminal diseases.
Josh Martins bed,
our friend I had just moved into a place
and he like, it's first night there.
Yeah,
you got screwed over by these two guys
that had a bedroom for rent and he gave
him the deposit and the first month's
rent and slept there for one night and
everything he owned since he moved it
all into his new bedroom got infested by
bedbugs. Oh No. Yeah.
And they're like really hard to
get rid of. You need to wash seal,
you need to seal everything and wash it
all at 110 degrees for an hour at least.
And you have to do all
this stuff with everything.
His mattress is now garbage and he's like
a very struggling young comics. Oh No.
So they knew about it before
they ran it in the place. Yeah.
So he's going to try to, oh, this is,
this is somebody that just came off of
living his in his car for a whole year.
Yeah.
In the last two months.
He was living in his car after it had
been peed on by another comic. Right.
Oh yeah. This is for guys just
not getting any luck. Yeah.
Fuck man. Bedbugs are supposedly
like all throughout New York City.
It's a real issue with bedbugs.
Yeah. Yeah. You know, I it,
because this happened to
him, uh, over the weekend.
I ended up reading about it
yesterday and it's really crazy.
They were almost extinct completely.
And then in [inaudible] 95 or something
like that, for no apparent reason,
there was an explosion of bedbugs. I
remember it just being, I, I used to think
they weren't even real.
I used to think it was just a thing
that my mom said to me before bed, like,
have a good night. Don't let the
bedbugs bite. Like that whole thing. No,
they're real. Dude. When I was in high
school, my dog had fleas and she, uh,
she got the fleas in my carpet
and I couldn't get him out. Man.
I could not get them out. Like when
I would go from my, my bedroom,
like from my carpet to my bed,
I would give bugs on me and don't have
to take them off that I had that happened
once. That was the scariest one of the
worst times of my life. It drove me crazy.
Feel like they're on you all the time
and I was a fucking lazy kid too.
I wasn't going to clean my room.
I wasn't gonna vacuum was,
I just wasn't going to get it done.
They jumped right on your ankles barring
remember that have a little scabs on my
ankles so I eventually had to pull
everything out of my room and then foam it
down.
We had to get this machine,
you know those machines and they hire
people to come by and you know you could
rent them and like home depot and shit
or whatever it was. I thought one of us.
Did you buy one if you ever need it?
Well I think carpets or gross man,
I would rather have a wood floor
that you can clean up real easy.
You can't really clean carpets that good.
It's like clothes that you never change.
I couldn't agree with you more.
I hate carpet. If it was up to me it
would just be, if you have hardwood,
maybe like a little rug and
then with something when
something spills on the rug,
get a new rug. Yeah. Roll that
bitch up fire. Absolutely. Yeah.
I think that's like a thing that people
thought was like a luxury in the 80s,
the 70s or whatever the fuck it was.
Carpet and they realize ah,
this is like a sweater
that people walk on, right?
It's like a giant towel is,
it's essentially just like a towel,
towels of those little things that stick
out of them. Who you mean plush? Yeah,
the fancier it is, the more it
entraps uh, bacteria and everything.
You know what I don't like?
I don't like towels that are synthetic
because you could feel it when they're
wet. When you're wet and you rub like one
of those plush synthetic towels and it
almost like doesn't absorb the water,
wipes the water on you a little bit,
like absorbed some of it,
but you could feel the difference.
Or if you get like a
real legit cotton towel,
you feel it like dry you off. You
feel it, like take the water off.
Those slippery ones make me feel like
I'm ruining the environment. Oh yeah.
I throw those out. Those
are my, I couldn't probably,
this print thing will probably melt when
you light on fire would melt. You know,
I saw you at e three. You're or I heard
your voice on the e three when you,
they announced the new UFC and they uh,
I've played some of it and they did,
I guess Bruce Lee is now in it. So you
can fight Bruce leave versus like GSP.
Dude. Have you seen it? Yeah, the graphics
are insane. They're insane. It's amazing.
There are so close now they're getting
so close to like making it look like a
real movie.
Like making it a real fight in HD.
And your own commentary on
that. Yeah. Did I did ours.
I was just going to ask like,
oh are you have to say like everything
cause you have to get every possible
thing out. Yeah. I mean
I'm not complaining but I
am kind of, but it wasn't,
wasn't like a difficult thing to do.
It just takes a long time. Right.
It's actually fun. I would just pretend
that was watching fights and you I would
just do it. Exactly. I
would, when I was doing it,
I would just think about
moments that things happen,
like moments like guys landed kicks or
you know punches or take downs or someone
catching the choke and I would just
remember like historic fight moments and
they're just sort of try to recapture
that and try to pretend that that's
happening while I was screaming at him.
So if you watch, if you play the video,
it's very close to the way I
would do commentary to real fire.
I love,
actually Chris isn't the best.
No one has ever been better than
the buffaloes total look up.
Good to fucking graphics.
That's incredible. My God,
I didn't realize this was the game
until you just said that. That's crazy.
Who gets the fucking
shadows and Dwayne is,
it's so much better than it used to be.
Exactly like Rhonda Rousey. That's
crazy. And look at the movement.
The movements really good.
Now
you heard the ground game controls are a
lot easier now to get into Jujitsu news
and stuff.
This
is crazy shit.
It looks so good.
That's a good team.
I mean it looks real.
Rarely been spending a lot,
but I'll tell you what,
people take a lot more head kicks
in this game than they do and feel
things. A couple of those jammies
in real life to shut the lights out.
This is wild.
Is it?
Is it weird to see all your friends
digitizing the Bruce Lee thing is amazing
if,
if you bring a Bruce Lee,
is he wearing the yellow and black?
You said that about right
gay as possible.
You can.
You can talk like that when it's
about Bruce Lee. You're allowed to.
Isn't that funny? Like ripped.
Ripped is a thing that people want.
They want ripped cod. They want
to see the six pack. Meanwhile,
the best fighter possibly ever was fate
or million inco and he was fat as fuck.
He walked around with like a belly.
You know, he had like a little role,
like helix jiggles around the middle
a little bit. It didn't give a fuck.
Just gone there and fuck guys up. Anderson
Silva was never that repped either.
You know, he was more smooth. It means
to obviously muscular and very strong,
but he wasn't like Bruce Lee and shredded
like it was a few guys that are like
that fucking shredded greasy like Batman.
Bruce Lee was like legitimately one of
the first guys to figure out that there
were certain aspects of all the martial
arts that were effective and the best
way to do it was to combine them all
before Bruce Lee. Nobody combined shit.
That was like a thing that you would
have pride in. You know, I have studied,
showed up, Khan, I will continue to
be a show con man to the day I die.
I am a wing Chung man, you know, I,
you know and people would like represent
their style like an old Fu movie,
you know,
where they thought that there was only
one style that was the correct style.
My master learned from the Great Masters
and he came down from Korea and taught
me this style. Bruce Lee
was like, that's nonsense.
Bruce Lee was the guy who invented
MMA. Really? What'd you do?
You fart covering your own mouth. I know
it was building my brand and my shirts.
You can't even go an hour without getting
you back on the vape pen to, yeah.
Did you get off the cigarettes? I
still smoke cigarettes. They age.
What happened man?
What was the stressful event that
caused you to go back off work stuff?
I didn't get something that I was
working for a couple months for really,
really hard and I mean, I'm going
to get back to, listen Tony.
I've got to get off in the long run.
It did you good? Trust me. Yeah,
you're, you're, you
shouldn't be on shows, Dude.
You should just get funny
just from your stand up.
I mean get famous just from your stand
up. Funny. Just from your stand up.
Get famous just from your stand up.
And the reason why I say this is because
no one is ever going to be able to
capture what you do best any
place other than onstage.
And you know when you're on
stage that's you. You're,
you're 100% in control of the content,
the way it's set up
delivered and it's hilarious.
Like you can't do that if
you're doing a TV show,
you're going to do with a bunch of people.
They're going to have some fucking wacky
ideas about what Tony h should wear and
Tony, we got like just a little bit of
makeup, just a slight base like okay,
okay and next thing you
know. Yeah, it was it,
it was a little bit bigger than that,
that the draining thing like it was,
it was something that like, I know,
I know what it was funny. Yeah,
I know what it was. He worked on it for
a long time. It was really tough loss.
If you're going to do a show,
I really think it should be your own show
just to figure out how to do your own
thing. You're doing somebody else's
thing. I think that's for a comic,
that's one of the hardest things to, to
realize. It takes a long time to realize,
but you're better off doing your
own thing. Then you are like,
if you get stuck on some show,
like when I was on fear factor,
it was a great benefit.
Financially it was really good,
but we doing someone else's
thing, it's not, it's like a job.
It becomes something that you think
about like, okay, now I'm going to work.
Not a complaining.
It was great job,
but there's a huge difference between
that and like doing a podcast or that and
doing, doing stand up, especially doing
stand up. Oh yeah. That's the freest one.
You're completely in control of how
you do it completely in control of what
you're right.
You experiment,
you come up with your own stuff and
you're not wasting any time doing anybody
else's thing and that then exactly.
I mean I wasn't going to slow down on
my stand up or you know the me thing,
but I really wanted that.
I really wanted something
that's, I mean that's a good thing that
you never stopped with your stand up.
Some guys do, right? They start,
they get a job writing and they stopped
performing. It's crazy. That was a,
that was one of the things when I got
into the writer's room for the first time,
I was amazed at how funny a lot of
the guys were and that they used to do
standup and that once they started the
writing job that they stopped because I
hang
out with comedians all the time, almost
every night. So when I was in the room,
I know what's funny and I know
who's funny. You know what I mean?
So it's amazing to me. It
was scary. Like one guy,
you know,
one of the funniest people I've ever
met used to do stand up and he doesn't,
every time this guy opens his mouth,
it's about to be an explosion. I mean,
he has an Emmy for writing,
but he's the king of roast riding.
Like he's just an insult
guru. So if you go, hey, what
about Bobby, Bobby, you know,
Jimi Hendrix or whatever,
and 10 seconds later he'll have a,
a gem that you can't not almost
fall on the ground at. So, but yeah,
I never did the entire time,
my first few years writing,
writing gigs, even during the
season, if it got late in the office,
eight nine, 10 like, hey guys,
I got to go a do my spot. Sorry.
But I'd also,
I'd also churn it out so much during the
day that they couldn't be like, well,
you know, I didn't give them an option.
I would, you know, hard all day.
But I never, if I did that, if I missed
a spot or something for a writing Gig,
that would start an entire,
whole nother crazy meltdown and breakdown
because I just can't not do stand up
crazy.
Well sure. You're always getting
better too. I'll see you.
I'll see you three months later.
You're better.
Three months later you'll be better than
you were three months ago almost every
time.
And that means you're like constantly
trying to refine and hone and that's when
it becomes like a real obsession when
you're like folding over your jokes and
hammering them down,
trying to get him to do,
you got to do a lot of sets to do that.
And if you have another gig that
starts preventing you from doing that,
he can become a real problem because
you could just go, oh, you know what?
I've got this. I'm just going to
like, I'm just going to kick back,
stop doing standup for a while.
I'm gonna just take a few months off
and just maybe I'll just, I mean,
I'm not happy with my act right now.
And you come up with excuses and
reasons and next thing you know,
you've got some sort of a job.
You're showing up at an office every day
and you're mean you're writing. Yeah,
it's great, but it's not as fun as
stand up. You can't be. Exactly.
But for some dudes, that stress
of the performance is not worth,
it's like a, it's not worth the effort.
It's like, what's that expression?
The juice like a, is it worth the
juice to squeeze these berries?
You know, is it worth the
effort? Is it worth it?
All this stress that you go through
to get onstage and crack out a joke.
I'd rather just write for someone
else and have them deal with it. Yeah.
That's not stress at all. I love churning
those berries. You know what I'm saying?
Why? But that's just you, right? Yeah.
I mean for some guys it really is
better for them to just be a writer.
It's like this, this, the performance
life is just too fucked up.
It's too hard for them. I guess so, yeah.
I think there's a lot of guys like that
couldn't get the spots,
didn't meet the right people at the
right time or something. I don't know.
Maybe they weren't that
funny of a performer. That
is the one thing, you know,
I don't know what those writers
who I say are Hilarious,
what their standups like.
They've been in writer rooms for so
long that they know how to be funny,
like at a table. You know what I, when the
topic comes up,
do you encourage people that you meet
that are really funny to try to do stand
up?
No, never. Never really. Never it.
They gotta want to do it.
That's one of those things where if
you don't want it so bad that you like,
you're crazy about it, then you're
not going to do anything anyway.
You never planted that seed though.
You never said to anybody you
should probably use stand up.
I,
you know,
my whole podcast is pretty much based
on helping people that want to do stand
up,
get better or grow or give them something
or in any way shape or form or bring
him down a peg if they're crazy.
But um,
I know I'm not into helping,
I'm not into telling somebody that they
should do something that's as extreme as
standup. Like if they
have, if that thought,
if they haven't gone to an open mic
and tried it then now I can't say,
you know why I say I do it is because I
think there's certain people out there
that really are funny and
just need to hear like I just,
a voice of encouragement can go a long
way. There's a, I met dudes that my,
I used to work for,
guy was private investigator,
one of the funniest guys I've ever
met my life. His name is Dave Dolan.
The great easily could
have been a standup.
He was a private investigator and he
was really good at reading people.
So he knew what a person's weakness was.
He would talk to you for a couple seconds
to just figure out what your thing was.
New played dumb. He'd be like this dumb
Boston guy. I can't, you know, you know,
it was down here with a friend of mine
and uh, we were looking for this guy that,
uh,
hit the,
hit our car and took off and he would
read off a license plate number.
It was very similar to their license
plate number and that was how we got
information out of people.
He would just tell them about an accident
that they weren't involved in and then
he would start talking to them and they
would start giving them information,
but all kinds of shit about working
while they're on unemployment. Oh,
I'm using my maiden name,
have a job. I'm like,
we caught people doing shit
like that all the time. Right.
But the guy was hilarious.
He would get in the car like after we
had done that and we would, you know,
we'd worked together as a team and he
would be laughing his dick off and just
saying all kinds of fucking crazy shit,
you know?
And he was just one of those guys that
was just naturally funny. And I told him,
I was like, look man, you're funnier
than me and I'm doing standup.
Like you should really do
stand up. And he's like, look
kid, I gotta pay the bills.
Okay, this is what I do.
I bust ass holes. Right.
They just had this sort of way about them.
Just knew how to just say the right thing.
Yeah.
It's like a craft that some guys have
where they know when to say the right
thing. Like is perfect
example, right? You know when,
when Eddie Bravo fought huddle Gracie,
we called Joey Diaz,
we had one speaker phone and
the first thing he said is
child,
the flags are at half mass
knows
when to say the right shit.
If Joey D is, if somebody's,
I guess he probably
decided to do it himself,
but if nobody had ever talked to
Joey Diaz and to doing stand up,
that would have been a national tragedy.
Yeah.
I know a lot of what Joey did was in
prison. Oh, who'd make prisoners laugh?
Yeah. I, that's where he got
good at it. They were like, he,
they wouldn't show a movie if the movie
sucked, they'd go get up there. Cocoa,
get up there.
Costco and Jelly would get up on stage
and make everybody laugh and then nuts.
Wow. When they tell the Joey Diaz life
story, and I think somebody will do it,
someone's going to fuck it up. Probably
be Jonah Hill or something like that.
Have some guys,
not even Cuban.
It'll be Adam Sandler was a fat suit.
Adam was a big fan and really
wants your trust in this project.
He probably thinks that he could do it.
It'd be like when people were outraged
that Tom Cruise was going to play this
stat and interview with the vampire
kids crazy online petition against Tom
cruise playing less data, but he's
freaking the fuck out. That's it.
It'd be like Jonah Hill was going to
play Joey Diaz. Yeah. They'd be like,
he's not even Cameron.
Hey, how are you? Cock suckers
and there be someone from like some
Latino Association who would get on TV and
say, you know, this is another
theft from the Latino community.
Someone has coming in and a non Latino
is playing a Latino on TV in a movie
about a Latino Star. Never. Yeah.
Cubano he'll ideas.
It's the best sauce of bashing.
The other day at the ice house
sold out the whole weekend.
I didn't know so many people knew
who Subash and why is that? Oh yeah,
he was that big, but people were
telling me, I will dude, he's huge.
Sebastian's doing great.
He had a showtime special,
we talked about a showtime special on the
podcast. I watched it in my hotel room.
I was just flipping through the channels
and I caught it. It was really funny.
He's fucking good. He's
doing really well. He, I,
he always done well in certain spots.
Like where people got to know him.
He developed a following
in Dallas years back.
Like you do really well at the added
that Addison Improv that places for
dickless. Hmm. That's a great
spot. That Addison Improv. Ooh,
that's a great spot.
That's what some wild people,
there's still a lot of smoke indoors.
I think
we'd do like a late show and people
would be smoking. I would go like, oh,
this is crazy.
You guys could smoke inside.
Like it was her and it wasn't
like one of those Vegas showrooms.
Like you can smoke in Vegas,
but if you go to any place in Vegas,
they have those fucking industrial
room cleansing machines,
socking cigarette smoker. You Walk through
the casino, you don't even realize it.
All those people are
smoking. Right? I mean,
how often do you walk through the get
mean? If you, if it's right on top of it,
you smell it and it's kind of gross.
But for the most part you're surrounded
by people smoking cigarettes.
You could barely tell.
It's just shocking out that air and
cleaning it up and giving you some fresh
ambition. Air, some blackjack air.
That's how I got back on the smoke.
So we were in Vegas just
a couple of weeks ago.
And you see these people smoking
in the casino and this I, you know,
it was just weird. I wasn't really,
there wasn't really planning on smoking,
but we got there and you just see these
people smoking but you don't smell it.
But it's indoors so it seems clean again,
like the trickery work,
my brain.
Next thing you know,
and when we met after we
checked into our hotel rooms,
I had a pack of cigarettes. Why
don't we do the first time, find that
out. How do casinos kill the
smell? Cigarettes? Cause they must,
they must do something.
We stayed at the Golden Nugget and we
had got it to the smoking room there and
the room smelled like the most cigarette
I've ever seen. The golden nuggets,
like the staple of Vegas. It's just
hundreds of years of cigarettes though.
Sinatra smoking there. Well, you know,
they say there's third hand smoke.
Do you ever hear about third hand smoke?
They think that you go into a place like
that that has been cigarette smokes.
People have been smoking in there
for years and years and years.
It's actually in the walls itself. Like
you're actually breathing in carcinogens.
We're in a building,
especially if anything catches fire or
gets wet or has some sort of a chemical
reaction to things that are in the room.
Household cleaners and shit like that.
It seems like something that you
would have said like three years ago,
you get cancer from third hand
smoke. You're a fan, you're a pussy.
Well,
I'm not saying that it's anything you
should worry about at a casino staying in
a room for a night, but it's not
good for you. That's for sure.
If they find out that's true.
Or if it gives you autism from smoke,
like third hand smoke is,
it seems like it would if it's like if
you go to that golden nugget that we were
at,
that shit was disturbingly cigarettey so
that place had like old school filters.
Oh, it's supposed to be. The rooms felt
like you were in an ashtray? Yeah, the,
there's a thing called the, okay.
There's a thing called air fantastic.
And they, uh, they have a solution
for these kinds of things.
It can reduce 99% of airborne
particles, particulates, dust,
pollen machines. Uh, this
is kind of interesting.
So I guess it just sucks all the air out
of the room and cleans it while you're
in there, Huh? Yeah.
That's pretty impressive.
99% of airborne particulates,
Jay Z.
It's like a study from
a West Texas a and m
particulates in cigarette
smoke are positively charged,
which keeps them airborne.
The ions produced are negatively
charged and so the particles,
the particles are neutralized
and fall to the ground.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
So this shit does something to the very
air around you that causes the particles
from cigarettes to fall so they don't
stay in the air and linger like that's
what's going on. What the fuck
is that about? That's weird, man.
Crystal Clear experiment was proven in
Austin's yellow rose gentleman's club in
2003, which installed eight
of our 14 inch probes.
That's hilarious. That's their
first fucking customer. Finally,
we got one bull is a titty bar taken us
in and we're going to revolutionize this
game.
The bar would be packed with many smokers
and the air was crystal clear and one
could not even see, uh, on particle.
They should say one particle
but says aunt on particle,
you fucking no spellcheck. Motherfuckers
read your own shit. How come someone has
a website that you don't
even read your own shit?
That makes me wonder if the product is a,
they could not see one particle.
You fucks in the bright
spot. Okay. All right.
Well that's just one company
that sells something.
But obviously there's something
like that. So they have, uh,
some way to remove this stuff.
There's more than one company is
another called Era Roma Air Zone.
So I guess they do something.
Huh?
I wonder if that's bad for you though.
Whatever the fuck they're doing to the
air, it seems like it would be like,
it's good, right? Yeah. I don't know what
the fuck that is. You got to do something.
If it's to the air,
how will do you have to be to smoke?
18 set in New York just passed
21 which is super smart. Yeah,
it should be fucked.
That 21 you got to got to stop.
You're not going to stop people.
I think if you want to figure out a way
to keep people from smoking cigarettes,
you're going to have to
find some sort of a, a pill.
Then that allows them to quit really
easily. It just kills the addiction.
No withdrawal symptoms because otherwise
the majority of people love pleasure
and they hate discomfort so much that
the idea of being without a cigarette and
having a Pang and a craving is too
much and they just cave in. Yeah.
It's amazing that Nabisco's
down with that. Yeah.
The people that sell us those
fine cookies and crackers,
they also sell cigarettes. I mean,
how coke greedy do you have to be?
Fucks how much money you make it from you
crackers so much enough fucking money.
Why do you have to sell cigarettes?
It's all that stuff.
You know those little sticks
with the little cheese.
What are those handy snacks?
Oh yeah. Four little white sticks
with the cheese. Same people.
How weird. Kraft is a Nabisco
company, so all that cheese, Oreos,
Oreos, a big one. How weird is
it that in this day and age,
with all the information that we have now,
we don't hold someone accountable for
something like that. We don't say,
why are you selling
that? Like, I mean, well,
people have the right to choose what
they want to do and a lot of Americans
enjoy a cigarette. It's amazing. That
was the scariest to me, honestly,
is really McDonald's.
Because why?
Because everybody's so taught that
it's Mcdonald's. It's America.
This is, this is good. You can, you
can, you can have, this is fine.
It's just cocacola fries, whatever.
This burger is made up. Yeah,
but that doesn't make you, well, I guess
it does a certain amount of addiction,
right? Oh yeah. It teaches you to
eat whatever preservatives are fine.
It teaches you that eat, eat
garbage. If it tastes good,
that's all that matters. I'm
loving it. Yeah, but is it,
is it doing that or is it just
giving you that as an option to like,
why is that any different than
a donut shop? I like donuts.
I don't eat them all the time, but I
like the fact that there's a donut shop.
Or if I pull into Dunkin donuts and I say,
Oh,
I have a cup of coffee and
a Boston cream donut please.
And I get excited and I'll have
about 1520 seconds of mouth pleasure,
and then a few hours of regret.
Yeah.
But I liked it. That's
available. That Mcdonald's
[inaudible] donuts, a special
treat. I think you go to a,
you get a donut that's like,
I'm going to pick out my doughnut.
This was baked today. Mcdonald's is like,
that's really the commercial, you know,
the commercials between
everything. It's sort of like, hey,
and they're the number one toy
producer in the country. Donald.
All those happy meals because
we're teaching kids, hey, eat this.
It doesn't matter what this
Burger is actually made out of.
You know, San Francisco
outlawed toys and happy meals.
That's smart. Is it? Yeah.
I'm telling you, man,
you can't just eat whatever you want.
You can,
but you can sometimes make you depressed.
It's going to make you angry.
You're going to wonder why
you feel crappy. I mean,
at least that's how it was with me.
That's why I had to get off.
That's to Mcdonald's. Yeah. I had it
last night at like quarter pounder.
It was like, yeah, we know it tastes
good. That's, that's part of the fries.
The fries. Yeah. But nowadays they, they,
they're getting sued by so many
people that like, you know, the oils,
they cook it in now or a lot
healthier than they used to
be. The, and the, the, the,
the quarter pounder,
the kerosene that they cook,
the burgers. Any food you make is
going to have oils. I know. Yeah.
But, but uh, yeah.
Yeah. I mean, because a lot of
people, when they seem their salary,
they're always worried about that
goddamn oil that comes with it.
Welcome to Greenly my salad.
I know there's going to be oil except
I meant when I eat anything with that
needs a whale like fries or
something like that. Or if you cook,
you can cook them in duck fat.
Remember that one place in Vegas when
we go to a craft stake, God damn son,
they bring over these duck fat fries.
Good googly Mowgli. Are they good?
One. One, one, one, one, one, one.
They bring them over with three
different types of dipping sauce. Oh,
but it's the duck fat. That's what does
it? Those fries, those McDonald's fries.
That shit's wack. So delicious. They
have the best ride. Mcdonald's. Yeah,
you're crazy. In and out.
He's worries. Make Tom in
announced. Sorry. Hardboard no,
no, no. It's like a real potato.
You fuck it actually tastes like a
potato in and out is fucking fantastic.
Oh good. It's good. I don't think
they'd beat Mcdonald's fries.
You know it's better than both of them.
Better than both of them. Five guys fries,
burglaries them in the fucking ground.
How dare you nod your head. Side to side.
Jamie, you son of a bitch.
You son of a bitch. Trust me.
Five guys fries. Fox, everybody
up. Plus they have a Cajun version.
You can get Cajun fries. Oh,
what did I say? Yes, they
give it to you in a fucking,
like one of those movie was movie barrels
where they give you popcorn after they
give you your fries. You never
need all your fries at five guys.
Good fucking luck.
Cajun seasoning is the,
uh, the best can. I mean,
that just makes anything
better. All Freezer, all fries
are good for at the Cajun.
But five guys does have a great Friday.
I usually don't fuck with Cajun spices
on steak. I usually like steak, you know,
like pepper and salt and that's it.
But I had occasion Ribeye at, uh,
that place we went to the other day.
Lordy.
Oh, it was perfect. Not too overpowering.
Just that right amount of spice.
Oh yeah. Their day. That looks amazing.
Of what delicious steak you're reading
or meat. Oh, uh, which one was it?
Oh, the bear. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
That was, uh, not the one I shot.
That was one that was, uh, someone in camp
shot. It was the first time I ever, well,
I had bear sausage before that I liked.
Um, but I'd never had like a bear stake,
like right off the bear was it taste
like taste delicious. Very Gamey.
Is it is it tastes like a pig. Fucked a
deer and you had to cook it. Well done.
That's good.
Yeah.
Well the problem with bear is the same
problem with pork and it's that they eat
animals and when they eat animals,
you have to worry about them having
tricky gnosis because tricker gnosis comes
from eating an animal that has
tricky gnosis. So like a aisle,
they say 90% of all the cases of tricking
osis according to my friend Steve
Rinella, 90% occur in the United
States from people eating bears. Whoa.
Yeah. That's the 90% of our
cases of chicken houses.
Think about how few people in
the United States eat bears,
but that's 90% of the trickiness
cases as his bears are. Um, they're,
they're predators. I mean, they
eat everything. They eat berries,
but they also eat animals.
They're responsible for like
half of the Moose population.
When you are in Alberta where I was at
half the babies get eaten by by bears.
Weren't you scared to eating
that like turning trick?
I mean getting turned to a bear?
No,
just you have to cook it to 150 degrees.
What's see what's,
I think bear meat would probably be
super delicious if you were able to
cook it medium rare. I would like
to try it that way because uh, it's,
it's good.
Um,
in comparison to like a like
beef or something like that,
it has a more robust
flavor. Like, and if you,
if you cook it like thin and you
have to kind of cook it well done,
it is very good but is not as good
as deer or elk because deer elk,
you eat like a medium rare,
almost a rare and it's delicious.
Like you see her like, like a deer
loin. You would take a slice of it,
you'd put like some pepper and maybe
some garlic salt on it and you would see
writ on one side and sear it on the
other side. It's fantastic. You know,
you don't really have to cook it that
much because they don't have the same type
of, uh, parasites that pigs
do. So when you have pig,
you always have to like that smoke
pig was amazing. That ham that I made.
But you have to cook that for a long time.
It's got to be cooked all the way through
and it really breaks it down and it
becomes delicious. But it has to hit 150
degrees if it doesn't hit 150 degrees,
that and Osis if it has it and it may not,
but if it does have it,
you could get it. So in that sense,
pigs and Behr are very similar.
I liked them a lot, but I prefer, um,
deer and elk and animals that
you could eat medium rare.
Have you ever done the duck
shooting? Like the, no,
it seems like as you would love that
because that seems like target practice.
I wake like you're just like, yeah. Um,
the only problem that I have with that,
and it's just a small moral problem,
is that a lot of those ducks,
you just sorta clipping them,
like you're like tagging their, their
wings with like pebbles, you know,
like you're shooting shotgun pellets
and if you ever watch those things,
a lot of those ducks are like still
flying after they get hit and then they
stumble and they lose a
lot of ducks that way.
Like ducks just fly off cause
it seems kind of not specific,
like you're shooting at them.
Boom, boom. But they spread out,
the pellets spread out.
And in a lot of ways,
and this is not a criticism
of duck hunting, I would
totally do it, but it just,
there's one thing that fucks with me and
that's that I think that a lot of them,
you're like barely going to hit.
You're going to hit like a
wing or a foot blow a foot off,
and then they're still gonna fly away.
You know,
you're going to shoot a lot of them
and drop them out of the sky. But if I,
you know, if you could shoot
one duck at a time with a rifle,
you could tune in on that doc. You've got
a cross hair on it, boom, the ducks gone.
But when you're pumping,
led into the air [inaudible]
you ever watch those duck shows?
Like sometimes they get them dead on,
but sometimes they like catch him and
there was spiral and they're, you know,
they're, they're fine. They
just fucked up, you know,
which happens with hunting too.
Um,
it happens especially
with the archery hunting.
Archery hunting is super dangerous and
it's dangerous. Obviously for the animal,
it's super dangerous, but it's dangerous
that you could, there's a danger,
a great dangerous should say that you
can wound an animal and not fatally
wounded. So you have to fucking practice
like crazy. It's really difficult to,
to shoot straight like you
think like a bow and arrow.
Today's bows and arrows are way easier
than the bows and arrows of cowboy and
Indian days or the Mongol days.
They're way better. I mean,
they have super high technology of the
sites on them. The arrows fly straighter.
They're like aluminum jacketed arrows.
The um,
the compound bows allow you to
pull like a heavy weight and it,
there's a lead off like an 80 pound bows,
like 80 pounds in the beginning.
But then back here it's only
probably like 20% of that.
So like when you have it at full draw,
you can hold onto it at full draw,
but it's hard to stay steady.
It's hard to keep that pin lined up on
the animal and you've got to [inaudible]
especially a bear when they're
coming out of hibernation.
Their lungs are only that big.
They're small. They're like,
like a small volleyball size,
you know,
like one of those kids volleyball's
it's not like a big long,
like a deer has a big long and l has
a big lung because they're in the high
mountains, they're running around all
the time. It's, they have a lot of,
but when these bears are
coming out of hibernation,
it's a very small area that you
have to hit. So it's not easy, man.
It takes a long fucking time to
get to a point where you, you,
you trust in your aim enough that you're
willing to take a shot at an animal
with a bow and arrow.
Serious Shit. Um, yeah.
Yeah.
Know anything about that stuff
you said cowboys and Indians and bears.
I just keep thinking I'm helping blown
my mind is that the village people wrote
the original,
I'm a Gigolo.
Like can you imagine how many van Halen
fans would get into an argument not
believing that the village people did
that first and what sounded like a little
bit of a catchy or version if you ask me,
like I sort of liked that hoppy beat,
I think to bring it around full circle.
Those guys were kind of bear.
Yeah,
exactly.
Because the barest one was the fucking
motorcycle cop or the, uh, the biker guy.
They shot their arrows into each other.
There's a lot of references.
Yeah.
So how many sit online that just Jessa
Jiggle it actually was written by
somebody even before that. Uh, I can't
find it now. I, it was that guy cares.
I believe that. Yeah. That makes sense. A
lot of those songs are like old, you know,
it's,
it sucks when you find out that your
favorite version of the song was like a
remake you. Yeah. Or that they
ripped it off from somebody.
Like bill burr called me
up once and he's like,
you're not even going to fucking
believe this. Go look up.
Led Zepplin rips off. He'd go, just
go, go look that up and listen to it.
And there's like a compilation with a
made a youtube compilation of led Zeppelin
songs and comparison to
the songs they ripped off.
They're getting sued right now from
that one guy that sounded exactly like,
it's devastating. It's devastating you,
you, I mean, I fucking love Zeplin Dude.
I mean,
and I can't take away,
it doesn't take away from my love
of those creations, those songs,
because the songs are
still fucking incredible,
but obviously obviously any song in a
band is a collaboration and it appears to
me that this was like an
unwilling collaboration.
That's how I would put it.
It was someone else's art that they
appropriated and made a part of their art
and they created something amazing and
that is essentially what plagiarism is.
If those guys had been a part of the
team and they work together, you know,
and this guy like, you know you need
cool then baby, I'm not a fool man.
I'm going to send you back
to school and you know,
and the guy writes it all down,
you're like Yay. I like it. I like it.
Like let's go with it.
That would be fine.
But if you hear that somewhere else and
then you just stick that in your song,
it doesn't make your song awesome.
No doubt. Whole lot of love.
It's one of my favorite songs of all time,
but that shit is almost directly
ripped off from some old blues song.
I mean like a lot of the lines like our
directly ripped off from an old blues
song. It's hard to listen to man. Yeah.
If you just type in led
Zepplin like plagiarism. TMZ,
there's like one from 2010. There's one
from 2014. There's one thing that goes,
it's just like a whole bunch of different
songs and lawsuits that have almost
all their songs are rip
offs. That's so crazy. Yeah.
I wonder if that's going to
cost them all their money.
That'd be fucking weird if all of
a sudden led Zeppelin went broke.
Like all those guys were broke as fuck.
Robert Palmer starts going on the road.
He's doing cover songs cause he owes all
this money and you want to hear one of
the, the the rip offs of Fuck Yeah.
This is according to the lawsuit, uh,
for dazed, confused, you know. Yes.
Love that God damn song
here is one of their big ones. Here
is the uh, I guess the rib offers.
Oh Great. That's the way. That's
the real version. That's okay.
Play in both playing together.
Yeah.
Stays it
Bobby and shoes.
Clue as to where it's the name of that
band cause led Zepplin who's than a
hundred million Jake Holmes.
This is not bad though.
Play that a little bit
more and that's the deal.
The only part is she. Okay. And here,
you know, of course the other one is
right.
Mother fucker
crazy.
Lots of people talk,
few of them know
was created.
Dave, they're better. I'm sorry.
I'm going to do the the Mexican
woman in the crowd. Yeah,
right. Yo, Yo,
Yo,
he did it better.
Yeah, I mean for sure. At the very least
they were influenced, but God damned.
Their lyrics are better.
The delivery was off the charts.
That's a fancy studio though. I'd like
to see that Jake guy in the same studio.
This studio band was a mother fucker son.
That is undeniable.
It was not just a studio.
It was the fucking output.
Just that guy's voice,
that output. Who the fucking hit those
notes. Who can even seem like that?
You know who the fuck things like
that man, play that shit again.
Play the Robert Plant version
again. Just play it. Play that part.
I'm way past that now. I can do
it fellow. You can do it. I know.
You know how to use the
Internet to find the
the stairway to heaven one
because it was way back,
but I just want to hear that real quick.
It's gonna be a better producer boy.
Damn
San Antonio now on him.
That was a crazy time.
You talked to Joey Diaz about led
Zeppelin. If you want to get the,
if led Zeppelin was smart,
they would hire Joey Diaz to narrate
their life story to just do a documentary
where Joey Diaz just explains led Zepplin.
Let me tell you something,
brother fucking dirty white guys from
swinging Dick on stage with fucking tights
on tights on Joe Rogan.
These giant cock is inches away from
women's faces and they're fucking losing
their minds.
They never seen nothing like this before.
He talks to you about like the invasion,
like when LEDs up and first hit America,
I'm doing it. No, you have to
hear him describe it. Like would that
song, the sound was, like I said,
nobody had a sound like that before.
So this is total new next level shit
that has opened up the door to a lot of
people's, changed a lot of people's
idea what songs sounded like.
Stairway to heaven. And I'm one
of those guys. I love, love,
I love led Zeppelin but I'm one of those
guys that puts pink Floyd ahead of them
any day of the week.
And that's interesting.
And put up a strong case for I know
it. I don't think you could. Oh yeah.
Cause it's better for you. But for me
it's up. It's better than pink Floyd.
But Pink Floyd's a fucking fucking
amazing. What does this sit again?
This is the whole, this is the guy.
Look at the guy above ground sound okay
of Jack Holmes. Is Jack Holmes
dead? Cause that'd be super ironic.
Jake Holmes.
That's definitely the baseline.
No doubt
she's sitting on his balls in
this country in shoes. Just Woo.
That's pretty God. Damn
good dude. Be a clue as to
do you lock a mouse and yeah,
I like it.
God damn good. I it's different but it's
pretty good. Pretty damn good. Yeah.
Hi. And I'm being abused.
And this Jesus is the crack
and see how he breaks it down
the right track.
All right guys.
It wow comes early.
That's pretty God damn good dude.
Yeah. Especially because it's,
that's the original.
So you gotta think like it's,
it's much easier to listen to someone
and then add a bunch of shit to something
that they've sort of the foundation.
Then the come up with the original idea.
Totally. You know, that's,
but that's the joke thief way.
That's what joke thieves do.
They'll take your premise and then they
change it enough so that they can get,
they can get away with it because
they made it better. Yeah.
They just said more to the
backend. So let's hear the,
the Robert Plant part. Okay.
Hold on a sec. Yeah, I mean
that's almost like, exactly.
Well those are the,
and Jake's version does
a courts and this is
good. Tell so long. That's not true.
Come on.
I want to fuck him.
And I'm a guy that I'm telling you,
these guys have these
guys said such better
access.
You would be in love
if you were in the audience and
you saw this, you'd be in love.
Be So enthralled, especially
1971 or whatever. Fuck it was.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
All right. Hair is a rip off for
sure. Check the yet. Definitely.
Now rip fucking off here is though.
This one I thought was kind of
messed up cause this guy even toward,
I guess with,
that's, that's the true medicine.
That's the Ari Shapiro opening.
It's called the Freddy Soto.
This is a group called Taurus and the
song spirit and it's the one that's there.
They're saying is from
a stairway to heaven.
So here is a spirit first.
Look how weird they look.
Yeah.
See,
these are the people that don't make it.
The ones that look a little weird like
give it, they wanted a pretty boy.
Yeah.
That guy looks like can Rigo Montoya you
killed my parents who killed my father.
Prepare to die.
Do, don't, don't hate on the man's art.
It's changed like it.
It's scary.
He's got a funky mustache on one side
and the other dude is bald headed.
You can be bald headed in 1971
or whatever the fuck this was.
Oh God.
Oh led Zepplin.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
fine.
Please don't steal our song.
Oh my God.
Where's this song though?
This is all music. I think.
I'm pretty sure that this
song doesn't have lyrics.
I think this was a notes here.
Really?
Yeah.
Well they, they got weird,
but it's their creation,
but they took it to a weird place that
it's the spirit of the song right there.
Absolutely. That's the song. Yeah.
I mean that's where it's easy
when you hear something like this,
just sort of create and she's
see cause like you feel how it
bugs you or how it hits you rather.
And then you add your creativity to it.
Right. The writing though, that's, that's
it in the lyrics isn't the
hardest part of the sun.
The hardest part of a song is
that part is that backbone,
that spinal cord of what's original.
What's different. I would've,
I would've assumed that you're right,
but I don't know Jack Shit about music.
How much do you know about music?
A pretty good amount.
I can play a lot of things.
Yeah. Wow. Yeah. Do Piano.
I have what they call perfect pitch. You
know what that is? You're a girl. No,
no perfect pitch is like one or two,
one or 2% of,
they don't know why it's not
like genetic or anything,
but one or 2% of people can
hear music like exactly.
So that if I play something or
if I'm in front of an instrument,
I can remember where that sound is and
know that it's a hard thing to explain,
but I can hear at the exact tone of each.
How do you know,
um, you find out when if you
take like piano lessons or like,
yeah, we are your people that play
by ear often have perfect pitch.
If you've ever heard that term.
Like there's people that can read music
and play and then there's people that
can really like pick the Beethoven play.
Perfect pitch is a perception thing.
It's not like a singer.
I thought it was like a singing thing.
It's on a sound that you,
well, I know, well if,
let's say that it's singing for example,
like I know if I hit the note exactly
so it makes it a lot easier to hit the
note if you know that, huh? Yeah. I
thought it was an ability thing, like a,
the hitting notes. I didn't know
it was being able to perceive it.
I thought it was just a setup to
make a sound that you can still,
you can learn it. Not Perfect pitch,
but you can learn how to make a sound.
Can you totally do. I mean, do
you have limitations on what?
Like I don't think I could
ever be a good singer. I know.
I really don't think I have any singing
talent. Like, Oh, you'd be surprised.
Like Vicky Lewis who was on news radio
has an insane voice, like insane,
like opera level voice like she can,
and I would,
I would like a church joke around,
tried to sing. She would get offended.
Like it was disgusting to her because
my clunky voice, I just, I don't,
I can't just hit songs,
but I've met people that they don't
even sing for a living. Right.
But they could sound, they sound beautiful
when they're singing. Right. Well,
it all depends. Like everybody should
just try to sing like themselves.
I just learned about this stuff recently,
the singing part of things for that one
thing that I didn't care anyway. Um,
but like you have to sing
in your singing voice.
You know how all this singer
sound different, you know,
Clapton and Tom Petty, hey,
is everybody doing it? They
like, he doesn't try to
sing like La la, la, la, la,
la La. He just goes with it and she's
a new can girl. You know what I mean?
Right.
So if you sing like how you sound instead
of trying to sing like what we think a
good singer sounds like, then you can kill
it because everybody sounds different.
They'll call and sounds
different than Roger Waters.
Cause according to David Gilmore
road, Robert Plant. Yeah.
I knew this dude who was in a,
and it was super
cocky dude. And then I finally
listened to his music. He's cocky,
bordering Douchey,
and I listened to some music and the
guy sounded exactly like Chris Cornell.
And when I say exactly,
I mean fucking exactly.
I thought it was like some lost
Soundgarden song from the early days.
I was listening to the exact same,
that same influx.
It was like me doing a
Joey Diaz impression. Yeah.
Like if I just started talking
like Joey Diaz or a onstage look,
if I went on stage and just pretend that
this is me now and now what's up cock
sucker. Where you at? Bitch, come
on. You would go, oh my God, he's,
he's doing a Joey Diaz impression,
right?
That's how much this guy sounded like
Chris Cornell. Oh yeah, we got, we got,
you're a Voodoo.
Punani Nah,
don't play it away. How dare
you. Different voices are fun.
That's why I like the crash test
dummies. You ever heard of them? Yeah.
Talks like this and everything.
And then when this song comes in,
it's like a totally different,
you can't fuck with checks though.
Chicks of the best sounding voices. My
opinion, I mean, I like Robert Plant.
He's got a bad ass voice.
But Janis Joplin,
if I had to choose between listening to
Janis Joplin sang a song or Robert Plant,
Oh yeah, that checked that
things gold finger pull up.
Take another little piece of my heart.
Why are you laughing? You don't know that
Janis Joplin Song. Right? It's great to
take it.
She was a fucking genius or me and
Bobby McGee. That's another one.
She was a god damn genius. Yeah.
Roller Skates is great. Yeah.
Yeah, that's right. We're the beamer
or ways a Mercedes Benz.
Oh Lord.
When I see shit like this,
when I listen to this,
I see in my head like a
documentary on the sixties toe.
That's what I see a
politician talking about.
These were innocent
times for scoring people.
This summer we're
embracing this new wave of,
of being there was sweeping the
nation and uh, we were a part of it.
We were at ground zero.
Yeah,
it was Berkeley in 1969
and it was all going on.
It was the freedom of summer put
play and pick her up. Crank her up,
listen to this
town.
No one of the things is so bad ass about
her when she would sing the pain in her
voice,
like the emotions,
her voice
that check and experienced a lot of shit.
It's one of those ones
that we get into it too.
She put her whole body and close
their eyes really get lost in it
and she was ugly.
Yeah,
she,
she was ugly and she hooked up with a lot.
Are Rock stars good for her big time.
Everybody wanted her
even though she was ugly.
Every guy wanted a banger cause
they're like that fucking voice.
She's got no tits,
no ass in the face of it.
Of a guitar. The Hell Charlie Brown or
female? Charlie Brown. Yeah, he's awesome.
Come on, Joey did. That
is scary. Oh my God.
Is that her?
Is that the exorcist is,
she looks like gimme it get a good
picture of it. Find a good picture of her
and I say ugly, like she's better
looking than me. How's it girl?
I don't know. She's pretty scary,
right? Like your ass instead of hers.
I think you could probably look
my ass. Period. Just for a story.
Just to be able to go on
and kill Tony talking about
she was okay.
Hippie chick put up a good one.
Oh my tutee. Oh, there's
a cute, if you're on acid,
you'd see your soul, your
lower soul or souls. Beautiful.
Complex. Like an old wine.
It's got that. Face flies.
I bet. How dare you. Oh,
my teeth are a little crooked. Other
than that, it's fine looking Gal.
Everything's crooked.
Look at that thing rude.
It's got demos through
one side of her face.
If I had to choose one woman to listen to
sing and she's up there. Amy Winehouse,
she's up there to Suzanne
Santo from honey. Honey,
it's right at the top of the God
damn list. She's got some new songs.
I wish we could play him, but she
didn't give me permission. I play uh,
some of our new shit. God
Damn Dude. Black women, man,
I want to shoot a lot of things. She'd
let us play. Are we allowed to? Oh sure.
I'm glad too.
Black women have this thing where they
have the most powerful vocal chords.
That lady that sings
gold finger from bond.
Did you ever see that live
performance like the Oscars or Emmy's?
A couple of years ago she got a standing
ovation afterwards. Solution Super. I,
it's, I can't believe, I can't
think of her name. She's the,
she's like the most respected Grace Jones,
something like that. If you're just
here, if you look up gold finger,
I guess Grace Jones. Grace Jones was
that black chick with the crazy haircut.
Yeah, like that Max head. You're
in black mixed hedge Max headroom.
Grace Jones was a, she used to
date Dolph Lundgren. Surely Lacey.
Yeah, that surely Basset, right? Yeah.
She is a cold blooded killer.
This is one where she got it and when she
does that, she's standing in when she,
she can clincher arms and it
makes the sound come from Kohl's.
She didn't, she know Polo and then go
low to high her range, which is thing.
Some people can do high, some people
can do low. She's one of those monsters.
A lot
of those guys clapped and pink Floyd.
They'd only work with black nurse
home owner. That's what it was. Yeah.
Everything sounds better
with a half boner.
Yeah. Pull up a honey honey. Uh, Angel of
death when they were alive on the roof.
This a video that they did.
I wanted to play one of the new songs,
but I can't get permission. So, uh, it
till I hear from her, I sent her a text.
If she texted me back during the shovel,
we'll try to play it,
but a video we're in. Yeah, that's
angel of death. But don't play that one.
Play the live one on the roof because
the live one on the roof is acoustic,
so you really get a chance to, to
hear her voice. This is a net, Brian,
is it? Yeah. Okay.
It's Tony Chirping.
It's me.
Yeah. This is how I found out about
these guys. They're moving back to la.
They gave up on Nashville.
God,
they heard that a few too many
n bombs and they were like, oh,
we're still in Tennessee
called angel of death
loaded until, ah, fine.
Do you,
isn't this an old village people song?
Let's say,
we'll just say they
never spend a single day.
I bet she's got talent.
Yes. Yes. There have been many.
Oh
yes,
I have treated them as you
tease day class Manny from Manny to you.
Hey,
I need to see them live again.
Yeah, they're uh, they're moving back
here, so we'll get to see him for sure.
Tell me back. Yeah, she's the best. And
should they have a new tour out and uh,
yeah. If you go to a honey
honey band. Dot. Yeah. Dot
Com. Um, they, uh, they have their,
their schedule up. It's there.
They're fucking awesome. And Ben
is the coolest guy. He's so nice.
He's such an interesting, funny dude
too. He's a cool guy to be around.
It's interesting.
No one people that can do shit that you
don't have any interest in pursuing.
You get to just watch it. Like as an
observer. That's how I feel about,
about music. You know, music is not
something that I ever wanted to pursue.
So when I watched people do it and it
really good, I find it super inspiring.
I never would've gotten into it at all.
However,
I lived in such a bad neighborhood.
I grew up in such a,
the worst corner of one of the most
dangerous cities in the country for years
it's been dangerous. But when I was
growing up, it was the most dangerous.
It's just houses getting
our sand everywhere. Makes
Detroit look like Youngstown,
Ohio. Yeah, that's a
bad, it's very dangerous.
The mafia versus the black gangs and the,
the black gangs versus everybody.
Notoriously one of the worst cities to
live in year after year. But anyway,
we had bars and all of our windows.
Uh,
it's just a thing that every house had
during that time, uh, late eighties,
early nineties, because people would
just, if they saw you leave your house,
they break into your
house and steal whatever.
But the only area that didn't have bars
in the windows was our dining room,
a window area. But since we, there
weren't bars in the windows. We,
my mom had an old upright piano that
leaned up against those windows,
so the light wouldn't even
come through the windows.
The only thing that would block
those windows was an upright piano.
So there was always an upright piano in
the dining room when I was being raised.
So I'd play it and just goof around
on it as a kid. But sure enough,
just to show you how bad of a
neighborhood I lived in one time,
because there were bars on the windows,
a guy with like an ax started breaking
through that window and broke all the way
through a piano and upright piano.
If you know anything about the guts
of a piano, I'm in, first of all,
the outsides made a crazy
old wood and this and that,
and it's all wood on the inside.
But there's all these metal
strings and everything.
They broke all the way through the
piano. Whoa. That's Youngstown for you.
Just the guy that started, he's
like, God, I gotta be close now.
Broke through the middle
of an upright piano.
And what happened to get
inside your house? I remember
they got inside my house,
they stole a mine Nintendo and the VCR,
which now would be,
I mean the oldest intent,
the regular Nintendo and a VCR.
Probably today's like $20
worth of stuff breaking. Um,
remember pretty specifically. I know
I was close to probably about third,
fourth or fifth grade writing there.
I know that because my first grade
play Christmas play was in the VCR.
It was so funny and we used to watch,
I used to,
I mean everybody in the family used to
watch it because it was so stupid. I was,
I was a star and I had a giant
head and I was so unacceptable.
Like they didn't want
to give me a good role,
so they just put a star
around my neck with a string.
So we'd always watch it
cause it'd be funny in that.
And that was in the VCR when they stolen,
there was no way to get that back,
you know? So that's why it really
stuck out hock. Yeah. Really
be a weird feeling to, to feel that
vulnerable. Like someone could break in
every night.
I was scared every single night.
Every single night I went
to better phrase, right.
We caught somebody breaking into
my house when I was really just,
it was like there weren't no, no, I
should, I should correct. It wasn't,
they weren't breaking in my house. They're
breaking in our car, which to right.
Right by the window.
And um,
I'm sure somebody probably would have
broken into our house, but we were home.
They probably knew her home.
I lived in Jamaica
plain, which was not nearly as bad as
Youngstown, but it was, it was sketchy,
especially now that now
it's all gentrified.
But back then it was pretty
fucked up and we caught,
this dude was right outside my window.
He's breaking into a car.
I remember seeing him run,
who's my,
my stepfather opened up the window and
yelled something or something. I forget.
There was some sort of an altercation,
like get the fuck out of there.
And then I remember like looking
down, because I had a, with my window,
my bedroom window was above the car
looking down and seeing this guy run off.
I was like,
this is fucking
Gary. Yeah. Really.
It's really gross when you realize that
somebody could mess with your stuff.
Well,
it's a weird feeling too.
Like you don't hear noises and then
you think this might really be someone
breaking in this time. Beanies.
That's what they would call them.
Kids in the neighborhood would
do it all the time. Oh, you know,
he's been to Juvie for a beanie. It was
like normal breaking an entering. Yeah.
Normal. No murders, bacon and
eggs over there. Very few murders.
Just a lot of crime. But it was,
it was possible to get murdered.
You know when you have a bunch of fucking
creepy people that had been in jail a
bunch of times and they're around a bunch
of other creepy people and there's a
lot of poverty and a lot of drugs
and fucking shit happens, man
kicking it all becomes acceptable. And
then the little brother is, and the,
and the younger people see their older
brother's doing it and they think it's
cool and that that's a part of life.
And then, you know, it's crazy.
It's also a weight. Guys make
money, you know, to be honest,
to break into someone's house,
you steal their TV and now you have a
thousand bucks, like, Holy Shit. Yeah.
It's fucked. The that, that doesn't
happen too much in rich neighborhoods.
Rich neighborhoods. Dude's
very rarely break into each
other's houses. Super Rare.
Yeah. It's something that only
happens if one person's got something,
the other person wants it.
What do you can get your own shit?
Shit doesn't mean as much. That becomes
a different thing. Become something.
How you judge each other.
That's where it's stupid,
but a lot fucking better
than living in poverty. Yeah.
Yeah. It was crazy. Youngest had a lot of
boxers come out of there. A lot of them.
Boom, boom, man. Sini
Kelly the ghost town. Yeah.
Kelly Perry Roya. How are you? Royal. Wow.
Kelly Pavlock had my favorite fight
that I've ever seen in all of boxing.
The Jermaine Taylor fied. Yeah,
yeah. Got An iPhone twice. They both,
neither one of them had ever been
knocked down in their entire professional
career. Not once. And
they both went down twice.
It was a great fight. Yeah. Pavlik was a
beast. Like the booze though. That's it.
Yeah, that'll fuck you man. But again,
I think a lot of these guys that liked
the booze part of it is just the pressure.
Yeah.
You know,
the pressure of being a professional
fighter has gotta be so staggering.
And in Youngstown, that's what your
Todd is. His drink, the pain away.
When he, every time he would go back
home, he was the king of Youngstown down.
And when you do that, you're just hanging
out at bars with your friends anyway.
And every single person that walks
in, hey, let me buy you a drink.
It's months until your next fight.
You know,
they don't realize it's a professional
athlete and he needs to make your mind.
Kelly,
what do you exactly how everybody
talks too good for a Jack Gum on Kelly.
Let me buy you a drink. Jack on
the rocks. Muck killing white
castle, big whiskey and a beer and
ain't going to hurt you. You know,
I didn't know that white castle had
tiny food the first time I went there.
And so I got it go. I got it
to go. I remember specifically,
I was at my brother's apartment in
Columbus visiting him in college.
Went to the white castle.
He was at work across the street,
got a burger and fries to go,
went back and I was so disappointed
because I was starving.
Went back and got three or
four more burgers. Yeah,
those were the days.
Yeah.
How'd they get away with that? Just
making a little tiny burger. Super cheap.
One Bite Burger.
They used to be a nickel or something
like that to daddy and it was,
that was the whole thing and like
get a nickel burger, you know?
But it was a smart man. But
yeah, I mean how many of those,
it was a regular burger, a quarterback.
Then how much is the regular burger?
Probably it was probably more expensive.
It was.
It probably some kind of
marketing thing like, no,
we got right like cheap burgers and Nicole
Beggs. Yeah, news breaking news. Joe,
do you see that thing
I posted the other day?
Did you know the U S P s or the
post office used to deliver kids.
They used to put the postage on the
kid and these carriers would have these
babies and they would just like take
me on the train with them and then it
started like, like getting
out more. And they may use
Snopes this. Yeah. Yeah. It's,
it's real. Totally real shy, shy
babies through the mail. Photos of it.
Yeah. You guys, what year was this?
Early Thirties, I believe. Oh,
so people were just worried that baby's
going to get eaten by wolves back down.
They took a chance to the post office.
Yeah.
But the people that would deliver
him the photo that I may show you,
it's like the creepy stuff.
All child molesters, you know,
he's stealing babies when you
couldn't track shit online, you know,
who knows where your baby is.
All right.
I can just do whatever they want
with your baby for a couple of days.
It takes a while to get
your baby over there.
Are you sure? Male babies wasn't spelled
m a l e like you weren't looking at it?
Yeah.
Wow. That's, uh, a mail
carrier with a fucking kid.
That's insane. Would have
stamps on it. What does it say?
Well, the, the tax making
it illegal in 1913 it was,
oh, scroll back. You
won't go up. Yeah, we're,
it was 13 it was legal to male children
with stamps attached to their clothing,
children road trends to the destinations
accompanied by layoff letter carriers.
One newspaper reported it costs 53 cents
for parents to mail their daughter to
her grandparents for a family visit as
new stories and photos popped up around
the country. It didn't take
long to get along on the books,
making it illegal to send children
in the mail. Wow. That's crazy.
They should make a illegal
against keeping us postal service.
Keep them in business.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Postal Service is not doing
so good anymore. Imagine if you were,
you made your business on sending
letters. You're like, look,
the post office fucking slow.
Okay,
I can get a letter to your friend in a
day if you have something to say to him.
Just letters don't packages.
I can get it to them and then all sudden
the internet comes along and the email
comes along. You're
like, fuck my business.
Exactly.
Imagine the guy just 15 years ago
that put all his money into male.
He's like, well, there's one thing that
will definitely never go away. Listen,
people pillar always Guinean to send
letters in a timely fashion, taxes,
letters, and trains. Three
things that will never go away.
No one saw text messages coming. No
one saw any of that comment. Right.
The idea that you could get on your email,
on your phone,
your phone weighs a fucking
ounce and keep it in your pocket
and the thing is coming in the mail is
a weird, everything should be digital.
Well, I think that they're going
to have two forms of delivery.
They're going to use drones and
they're going to use three d printing.
I think that's what's going to be a
lot of products in the future. Oh yeah.
I think you're going to have some sort
of a box in your house about the size of
regular home computer printer.
Need a bigger one for bigger things but
you're just going to own like you're
going to use like bitcoin
to buy the directions or buy
the ingredients or by the
uh, the, the, the, the
schematic work, whatever.
You download that schematic into your,
your computer press print and that fucker
just develops it right there on your
box.
That's going to happen.
And the drones will have little,
the,
every house will have a little chimney
drop where the drone just goddamn Santa
Claus. Yup. Say like you left your, your
iPhone at home where your phone at home,
right. It's going to know your phone
and said like, Hey, I need you to print.
Send me my phone.
So they,
you would have to put it in a box because
you only have one license for that
phone and then it will reprint it in your,
wherever you want to
destroy your original,
the original one because
you only have one license.
What if it becomes like a clone?
Like,
remember when you get a VCR tape that
somebody made off of a VCR tape and it was
kind of whack and like, God,
his phone's not so good.
It's a clone to clone of your phone.
A three d printed clone. Yeah,
but it's all the data
download cloud cloud.
Every time you drop your
phone that you're like, yeah,
I just need to send my phone again
and get her, you know, reprinted.
Yeah. You just get a new phone,
whatever the new one. Yeah.
Yeah man,
I got to do I clone six a
well,
you know,
it'd be really dope if you could take
old phones and you throw them into the
computer and like dad eats him
up and build a new phone. Right?
Like whenever a new schematic comes up,
it can actually extract and recycle the,
the,
the components of the device
car. Like every day you go,
like, I want to drive today.
I want to drive a Porsche tomorrow. I
want to drive some, you know, whatever.
Shitty, but car, your transformer,
by the time we're printing out cars,
we're not going to even have cars anymore.
We're going to have little
thing that you just get in.
It looks like an egg pretty much,
and you're just going to
sit in it destination today.
You won't even tell you.
I don't even know why I'm doing that.
You're already in the thing.
I want to go to,
uh,
the roller coaster park and I'll go,
do you want to go to the roller
coaster park 37 miles away? Yes.
And then it, you can make it so
that it won't hit anything else.
Good goal or has it?
I'll do you one better. I think we're
going to transcend physical reality.
That's what I think.
I'm not going to,
they're going to develop an artificial
reality that is more complex and more
rewarding than the physical reality.
And so no one will exist in
the physical reality anymore.
It would all be even maintained
from this artificial reality.
We will maintain this dimension from an
alternative dimension that we create and
children will be born instantaneously
into this alternative dimension because
the fucking fear upon fears
is that your kid will be born,
the natural world would get
eaten by animals. Fuck that.
There will be no children born.
We're going to figure out a way
to transcend the physical reality.
So whatever consciousness
is when it's created,
when a man and a woman have sex in a
baby comes out of the woman's body,
that baby will immediately be transported
into an alternative dimension.
As it's being born.
We're already in it. Maybe I saw your
post the other day and bug's life thing.
Yeah.
I had just taken all my DVDs out and
reorganize them and I had just looked at
bug's life cause I lost the DVD.
I don't know where it is. Yeah.
Dream about Dave Foley.
I was in a onetime in bear camp.
I was in bear camp and uh,
I was a dream in a day.
Foley was like healthy and he
was like thin and Smiley. Yeah.
It was like when I knew him in 1994 when
I first met him on news radio and then
I got up in the morning and
I went upstairs and uh, uh,
I sat down in front of the TV and a bug's
life came on and there was Dave always
voice. I was like, wow, that's weird.
Cause he did that like around the same
time we were doing news radio, that guy,
if I feel bad about any guy getting fucked
in a divorce proceeding, you want to,
you want to find the worst case scenario.
I mean not worst,
I guess worst was Phil
Hartman, his fucking wife
killed him when he's sleeping.
But close to worst of a guy
getting fucked over by a divorce,
alimony laws and child support laws.
Look, look up Dave Foley and look, uh,
look up.
Dave Foley discusses a child support and
alimony from our podcasts cause it was,
it was heartbreaking because they got
him locked into a payment schedule based
on what he was making
when he was on news radio,
which was a crazy amount of money.
And he's on NBC.
He was on a Sitcom and he was one of the
big stars of it coming from kids in the
hall. He was a well known comedian.
They gave him this great big deal.
And the show was sort of written
around him and Phil Hartman. And, uh,
you can't expect to make that kind of
money your whole life. It's incredible.
It's incredible.
It's an amazing opportunity.
But the idea of a sitcom is
it's a once in a lifetime thing.
Very few people ever get one and
one that goes to syndication.
And what you should do is stockpile as
much of that money as possible because
the chances of getting
another one are quite slim.
But that's not how the divorce laws
look at it. They look at it like, look,
this is what you make.
You owe x amount of percentage of that.
So if all of a sudden you make,
you went from $1 million a year
or whatever to $100,000 a year,
you still have to pay a half a
million dollars a year. Like you stay,
whatever the fuck it was. What
did it make up enough? Wow.
So he developed more than,
it was more than a half a million dollars
in debt that he could not pay off.
I mean,
I don't know what it was,
but I remember at one time it
was a half million. It was,
it was compiling and he couldn't get into
the country because if we went to the
Canada they would arrest him.
I mean it's crazy fucking shit.
He was having meetings.
They were refuse to reduce the amount
of money that he had to pay and it's not
like a matter of like them getting
money for food and money for housing and
clothing,
which totally makes sense.
It was exorbitant amounts of money and
she was flying all over the country with
its money and going to foreign
countries and spending all this money on
redecorating the house. Like he would
talk about it and would drive him crazy.
It's, it's a, it's a wild because
Canada doesn't let you get divorced,
like as easy as you
doing the United States,
you have to be separated from each
other at least at the time for a year.
But during that year she gets access to
your bank account because you have joint
accounts. So during that year
she would spend with impunity.
I mean she would,
she would try to break him.
She would try to break him with her
spending and though he talked about it on
the podcast and you see the guy was
just devastated by it. Just devastated.
Like that's a real extreme example.
Like one of the most extreme examples.
Most of the time,
you know,
it's like we were saying that that video
earlier with that kid was getting beat
up by that woman and he was doing the
selfie and he's like, stop assaulting me.
And then when the cops came she
said that he assaulted her. Right.
Thankfully he had that video.
Yeah.
I think in a lot of cases,
like when people split up
and when people get angry,
people go from love to hate and
in pretty extreme variation.
Like people who like
people who love each other.
When you don't love that person anymore
or that person don't, doesn't love you.
It's not just like you don't get
along anymore. Like friends. It just,
I don't hang around with them anymore.
It's like they stole something from you.
They stole a piece of your happiness.
They stole a piece of your love and they
get fucking angry and they'll make shit
up. They'll say, you touched your kids.
You did a bunch of creepy shit to them.
You'll beat them up. They'll beat
themselves up and blamed it on you.
They'll hit themselves with shit and
blame it on you knowing that most of the
time cops are going to believe him
cause guys hit women all the time. Yeah.
It's scary to be stuck in them.
Crazy situation like that where someone
who used to get intimate with now wants
to lie and plot and do
anything to drag you down.
You got to have him back and see if
he's happier now because that really did
make me feel very sad when he was here.
Yeah. It made me sad too. I, you know,
I know he got a sitcom after that for a
bit and then they did a comedy festival.
Had Dave Foley just about two
months ago and understand them.
Was he doing on it was hilarious. It was
awesome. He's a funny dude, man. Yeah.
He could have been spent in
doing stand up the whole time.
But we had a lot of fun.
He's always done a sketch,
comedy Improv and stuff like that,
but he could have easily been a stand up.
He's a very smart guy.
He's on a show now with Kin Jong and uh,
Ken wants to come on the show office. I
mean, we have both of them on. Oh yeah.
What's the, what show was
it? I don't know. I just,
I've been seeing them on
Facebook. Uh, they're filming.
It was awesome. Oh, 10 minutes.
We got to rub this picture up.
Tony Motha fucking Hinchcliffe time
flies by when we shoot the shit.
We gotta get you on killed Tony
Saying, oh, it'd be happy to,
if you didn't do in the devil's ball
sack k the comedy store come to a fuck.
Respectable venue and a, I'll race
you with my services. Of course.
Bring that pitch to the ice house.
I'll do it at the ice house,
but I can't go back to that place.
I just can't. I know too much.
I know to watch Tony
the next Friday you have open.
We'll just make it okay.
Yeah. Okay. Let's do it. I would love
to do that. That'd be fun. And uh,
if you haven't watched or listened to
kill Tony, you can catch it on a desk.
squad.tv. It's on iTunes
and also on desk squad. Dot.
TV is, um, the other one that we talk
about all the time. Thunderpussy yeah,
throwing to Pussy, which is a fun,
fun time with the right crowd.
Occasionally you get the wrong
crowd and it becomes a fuck fest.
But with the right crowd, the comedians
go on stage and just the audience,
he yells out ideas and the comedian
starts to talk about things.
They just re make comedy up on the spot.
It's very challenging but very fun.
And it's also a way that you wind up
coming up with a lot of new material
because you're just completely riffing
as long as the audience is cool.
We've had both. We've had,
when the audience is awesome.
And the last time it was a dog
show, but yeah, that was, yeah,
that was fun. The last
time, but those guys,
there was a few people definitely
that were out of control.
We bought a little bit of the [inaudible]
I went up first mind just so I knew it
was going to get out of control cause if
the three guys are bugging me I'm like
oof,
this is a ticking time bomb.
And I tried to acknowledge them and
calm them down and let them realize that
they seemed wasted right from the get
the few people that were just out of it.
Like you're a totally,
you know when people,
you know audience members ways to
when they're like answering rhetorical
question, you know? Yeah. Like
you know what drives me crazy? No,
I don't know what drives you
crazy, you know? It's like
just trying to get attention.
That was a problem.
It wasn't simply a matter of participating
or yelling out topics they were doing
were they were like
trying to get attention.
They were trying to be a part of the show,
right?
Like the guy to the left whose buddy got
kicked out early and then he just kept
going like, dude, your buddy's
already been kicked out.
Like you guys are too drunk. Like, yeah,
you gotta learn how to handle your
liquor sign. Yeah. Do you know how people
we're looking at, you know, no thing is,
is that that show is also 18 and up
though. Yeah. That's not cool. No,
no. I don't know. They need to change
that. She, yeah. Am I allowed to tech?
Because I mean, I love, I love that
age group, but they just, you know,
if I know they're underage
drinking, going on, not there,
but maybe they came drunk
or whatever and it adds,
probably they could bring flasks.
Nobody's checking their bags and
they walked through the door.
All these problems that we
had at the last Thunderpussy,
it was at the beginning of the show.
So there's no way that they got drunk
at the Eisenhower came in strong.
So I think what's happening is people were
just coming like fucking balls, wasted
10 year old kid that got kicked out,
just like so sad.
He was just sitting there on the bench
outside. And I'm like, what happened dude?
He's like, man, I got kicked out. I was
like, look, it's not the end of the world.
Got to realize like it's part of being
young. You fuck up, you get drunk,
do retarded shit and then you
realize you did retarded shit.
So the next time you think you're going
to get into that same sort of situation
again, you correct yourself,
you'll be all right.
Then we saw he was so devastated
at the beginning of this next
Thunderpussy the one that we just did.
I spent my first three minutes on that
guy because I realize that if I didn't,
if I didn't acknowledge him right from
the get then cause Jeremiah even told me,
cause he hosts it. So Jeremiah
went up first, then he
brought me up. Jeremiah goes,
I knew I purposefully
didn't double. Uh, you know,
I didn't want to seem like the bad guy.
I knew that you would like to take that.
So I didn't even acknowledge
him cause you know,
Jeremiah and I worked together a lot, uh,
like at the store. And just everywhere.
We're both, you know, both grinders.
So anyway, he knew. He knew
you're on Grindr. No, we don't
grind each other. No. Yeah,
dog. No, it's out there on the grind,
you know, that's like a rap term. Yeah.
Hustling.
He's hustling every day.
Everyday. Everyday. Everyday we bees
hustling's yes. Um, but uh, yeah,
so I
worse is that those guys think that
they're helping the show. Well,
that's the worst.
That's why if I'm first or second,
I have the chance to help out the show,
I go and you're not going to help the
show. You might be thinking that you're,
you know, I like, I've built over the
years of acknowledging these people,
I've built jokes on them. You
know what I mean? And you're,
you're gonna think you killed tomorrow
at the water cooler, but you didn't,
you know,
you gotta just tell him the truth because
if they think then that they're going
to help the show, you got to nip it
in the, what is it? Butter, butter.
Brown. The bug. It's like a
plant. Nip it in the bud. Yeah.
That's what you're supposed to do. Yeah.
You actually pull it out by the roots.
That's the best way. Nip it in the bud.
What if it re rebuts true? You know,
why would you plant still alive? Don't
just nip it. Pull it out of the roots.
Then light that thing on fire. That's
what you're supposed to be, man.
Imagine though,
being 19 years old and getting drunk
and come to a comic show where you're
allowed to talk to the Comedians,
you're allowed to yell out ideas.
There's no four. I mean that's like part
of the fun when it works out great. Yeah,
but part of the problem with that is if
you get the wrong kind of kids in there,
especially young kids, 18
years old, hammered for the
first time yelling shit out.
Edibles and weed. Yeah.
Yeah. I couldn't fake ids
by the way.
Highly recommend.
See Louis C K is new latest episode where
as he catches his daughter's smoking
marijuana.
It's like an hour and a half long episode.
One of the best things I've ever seen
ever and Louis C K is a maniac man.
Are you? Are you watching any of his shit
or watching it as it was really good.
I almost went to watch it like
three more times in the kids.
The kids that used in at the actors, Bravo
to those guys. I mean it was beautiful.
Wow. His daughters are amazing and
they steal it a lot. All right,
so great. I haven't been watching
it. Do you watch game of Thrones?
Yeah. Don't talk about it though, is
a lot of people get mad. Oh, I bet.
Spoiler alert. I just caught up on
a, the episode this week. Last night.
Holy Fuck. Yeah. Such a good show.
After it's over, you just go home.
Fuck. You want to watch something? Great.
Watch a show on Netflix called the
writer's room and just go straight to the
game of Thrones episode.
It's the two writers.
They worked directly with George Martin.
So Jordan though,
they're the ones that take George his
ideas and then with their imagination put
it into film. It's two guys and
it's been to the whole time,
but they don't work together.
They sit in opposite rooms.
They don't even work on the same episodes.
What one guy,
they do one after the other,
so one does one and the one does the next.
And the reason why it's
so great in my opinion,
if you watch the this episode of the
writer's room called game of Thrones,
where it's these two guys,
you figure out that they're
just trying to outdo each other.
These guys are writing partners
and they're just trying to be like,
I'm going to blow your mind
this week, Bro. Yeah, exactly.
That's incredible. Yeah. Pitted them
against each other. Yeah, exactly. Wow.
But they're together, but they're against
it. It's sort of like, like pink Floyd.
If he had the, the two main guys, Roger
Waters and David Gilmore with notorious,
like when you hear a band breakup,
like it's sort of built off of pink Floyd
because they didn't play together for
20 or 30 years. The notorious
huge breakup at the massive peak.
And uh, but that's what they would do.
Like Roger Waters, it'd be like, you know,
hey buddy,
a under lead creative force and I
just wrote this album called the wall.
It's a shame you didn't get anything in
on it. And David Gilmore and be like,
oh yeah,
mother fucker.
And he would go in a room and write
comfortably numb and come back with that.
But is the two biggest, you know, some
of the biggest guitar Solos of all time,
which is the little pin. Yeah. With
his voice that David Gilmore does
and says that's the same thing.
Those two guys always hated each other,
but they're a band and it,
and it helped because Roger Waters
would go check out these lyrics in this
baseline, bro. And then Gilmore, it'd
be like, Oh, you think you're a bad ass.
We'll watch this guitar solo. He would
try to steal the song from him. Wow.
You know,
by like laying it down or using his voice
and waters was smart enough to let it
all happen because
that's good for business,
isn't it?
Like every band that's ever a huge band,
don't they always have a problem with
the lead singer and someone else?
Like even fucking van Halen. Van
Halen broke up. David Lee Roth left,
they brought in someone else.
They brought in Sammy Hagar than
they brought in that other dude.
Remember that other dude who's the
other dude did they brought in for,
it was from a good band, but he sucked
it as the lead singer of Van Halen.
It just didn't work for whatever reason.
Yeah.
But think axel rose and guns and roses,
Mick Jagger and Keith Richards,
they keep it together. Totally.
But apparently like Keith,
Richard talked a gang of shit
about Mick Jagger in his book,
which is Steven Tyler. It was guys
Harris, but they left for a while. Right?
Didn't Joe Perry leave for awhile?
He did. Right? Yeah, I think so.
Joe Perry is a cool motherfucker. I'm
friends with him on Twitter. Really cool.
Joe Perry, um, he's a conspiracy theorist.
He didn't a lot of conspiracy theories,
man. Some wacky ones. But uh, like I
found a rock at the beach and I was like,
what is this rock? This is a volcanic rock
and a or media or something like that.
Cause it, how long has holes in it?
Couldn't figure out what it was like.
I remember looking at that and
it was, uh, apparently fish too,
that it's like a see stone. Yeah. Joe
Perry told me on Twitter. I was like,
what a crazy world we live in with Joe
Perry can give you explanations of what
kind of rock. Well, the
greatest guitars ever.
And he knows all about rock and knows
about shock and role, knows about geology,
see rocks and shit. I'm Brian. You
got anything going on this weekend?
Uh, tonight. Ontario Improv
Friday ice house. Uh,
I'm going to Florida with Sam
Tripoli in August. Uh, April 8th,
ninth and 10th. Uh, Tampa,
Jacksonville and Orlando.
Good Lord Son. Um, and
like I said this weekend,
Tony and Brian Cowen and I, Thursday and
Friday. I shouldn't say this weekend,
Thursday night we're in Lloydminster
and then uh, both of them are in Canada.
So if you're like, what the fuck's
Lloydminster it's another country bitch.
And the other one is Vancouver at
the Orpheum theater on Friday night.
Can't fucking wait.
Brian Cowen,
Tony Hinchcliffe and Wa good times.
You fucks. All right, thanks Sam. Hey,
anytime my friend, anytime. Uh, that's it.
Fuckers. Thanks for, uh, the sponsorship.
Mr Squarespace. Go to squarespace.com uh,
and build yourself an awesome website.
You freaks and use the code word
Joe and save 10% off your first
purchase@squarespace.com thanks.
Also to ting,
go to rogan.ting.com and uh,
get an awesome deal on cell phone service
for a fraction of the cost and all
kinds of good shit that goes along with
being involved with Ting rogan.ting.com
we'll save you 25 bucks off of
your first device. Go there,
enjoy it.
Go to [inaudible] dot com use the codeword
Rogan and save 10% off any and all
supplements. We will be back
tomorrow with ends in anyway.
Returned to the podcast,
the great Yamaha told the mushy one of
the old school MMA fighters a real legend
and a cool ass motherfucker.
He will be here tomorrow at noon.
So much love until then. Enjoy
your life. You dirty fucks. Tony,
did you have a tour dates,
Tony hinchcliffe.com
oh yeah.
Tony hinchcliffe.com at Tony Hinchcliffe
on Twitter and check out two absent an
e at the h plus inch,
Clif plus C,
which reminds me of that tee shirts
available at Tony and tee shirt.
You fuck support the kid.
He's got talent.
All right. We love you guys. Much
love. See you soon. Big Kiss. No.
[inaudible].